if anybody sounded the alarm then all
this madness was gonna come to fruition
in the real world it's you sir
you were you were the guy like you were
the one who's saying this is what's
happening at Evergreen and if you don't
know go google it
Bret Weinstein evergreen and now it
spills out into the real world just like
I said it was gonna you did I didn't I
did I said it in several different
places and pretty clearly you know it
could have been a tiny bit more
precision but I was highly accurate you
are highly accurate and often maligned
and mocked
yeah people didn't think it was a big
deal they think you were much ado about
nothing you're making a big deal about
some kids that are voicing their
opinions on things but what you
recognized early on was that there was
an authoritarian aspect of it a forced
compliance aspect of it that's very
dangerous yeah it's all about force and
you know I've started to get calls in
the last week or two the people who who
mocked me and others including you for
making too much of what appeared to be
college kids going wild on college
campuses some of them have started to
call and say I got it wrong what do we
do now and actually I I appreciate those
those calls in those contacts because
really that is the question you do now
to pull it back yeah the genie back in
the bottle or as Douglas Murray says how
do you put the brakes on this thing how
do you put the brakes on this thing
indeed well I have to tell you I'm not
optimistic I think this is actually the
people who are catching up to the fact
that Evergreen has now spilled over into
the world
I have not caught up to the fact that
this is unstoppable at this point with
the current configuration the absence of
leadership is going to prevent us from
doing what we should do and that means
that the next set of predictions are far
more dire what is your next set of
predictions well I would say we are
headed for a collision course with with
history I mean we're really staring at
many scenarios that end in
kind of civil war and while I do think
it is still possible to avert that
outcome I don't know the name of the
force that gets in its way that's it's
really troubling what do you think these
kids want not just kids what do you what
do you think the people that are
facilitating chaos what do you think
they want well I think there's some
danger in casting them as one thing
because I think we have several things
fused together and that until you
understand what has joined forces with
what you're not gonna there's no way to
answer the question all right let's
break it down okay so one thing that
we're seeing is and we really have to
take this back a number of years to
understand why it happened but we are
seeing occupy 2.0 mm-hmm now I
participated in Occupy originally occupy
made a lot of sense it was a complaint
about the tarp program and too big to
fail and the fact that the American
public was not protected when those who
had created the financial collapse were
and that was a legitimate gripe and it
was also a legitimate gripe at the
beginning of the Tea Party movement
occupy then morphed into a an anarchist
movement that was just simply hostile to
civilization and it became absurd and so
when I say this is occupied 2.0 this is
the anarchist version of Occupy that has
now reemerged and it has fused with
black lives matter which as I've said
lots of different places if black lives
matter just simply meant with those
words imply I'd be on board with it it
doesn't it means a great deal more than
that and we're beginning to see that in
the last couple of weeks what else do
you think it means
well let's put it this way for some
reason it means abolish the police which
is possibly the stupidest proposal I
have ever heard and it's not like we
haven't seen what happens when you do
that I don't you think that's just a
fearful response to the obvious police
brutality that we saw in Minneapolis
what's the best response we got to do
something
we need to defund the police and then
everyone's like good job great
great first step at least well no it's a
dishonest presentation and I'm concerned
that there as I've also said in many
places the proposals that are coming out
of this movement are quite foolish the
strategy is incredibly smart and so that
is confusing to people because when you
hear folks in the street demanding that
we abolish the police you think well
okay that's never going to happen if it
even started to happen it would be so
complex to make it happen that it can't
possibly be they just need to blow off
some steam nope that's not right the
fact is the police in some places can
effectively be halted in their tracks
and really if there's one most important
lesson out of the whole Evergreen fiasco
it's that the police can be withdrawn
from a situation and chaos takes a
matter of hours to emerge which we are
also seeing in Seattle yeah the
defunding of the police which is
happening in Minneapolis what are they
doing in replacement of the police well
I don't know and I will say that the
thing that is trotted out as the example
that tells us that defund the police
which doesn't really mean do you fund
the police it means abolish the police
we are told that that's safe on the
basis of something like the Camden
example what Camden just did they sort
of broke the police down but then built
up a new version of the police right
yeah they shifted it to a different
jurisdiction and look I'm not arguing
that we don't need massive police reform
and frankly I'd be up for a discussion
of a total rethink of the way we do
policing but the idea that you could
withdraw the police first is absolutely
insane mark Lamont Hill had a very good
point about the guy who was killed what
it was a gentleman's name that was
killed in the drive-in to drive through
a fast-food place
Rashard says his name who was just drunk
and compliant and peaceful until they
were telling him they were gonna arrest
him
even said get me an uber and what his
point was there's a very good point why
were the police even called for that
this is a non-violent person who just
happened to be drunk
was he doing something he should have
been doing yes but obviously compliant
polite speaking well just like very
reasonably until it escalated into this
tussle and then he lost his life if they
had just had some sort of a program
where they could we're gonna park your
car sir or we'll have someone Drive your
car to your house we're gonna call you
an uber or we're gonna take you home and
we're gonna just write you a ticket and
work this out in court you're not gonna
go to jail you don't have to be arrested
you don't to be handcuffed you're gonna
be treated like a monster you [ __ ] up
you made a mistake but you're not a bad
person you know as a person who's trying
to hurt people the police should be
there for robbers murderers rapists
that's that's what we need the police
for and this is another none of those
things this is just a guy who [ __ ] up
and he got drunk and he and then as they
were speaking to him clear real clear
not a bad guy like the way he's talking
to cops just talking to him very
reasonably even asked for an uber well
look I am no fan of this aggressive
style of policing you know not a fan of
the militarization of the police I've
actually I mean I've had run-ins with
the police I've been hit twice by cops
so it's not going to happen well one of
these is a long story that goes back to
my first research gig in Jamaica and the
other one was I was participating in a
protest I mean I was very young I was
probably 20 and there was a protest
about homelessness in Berkeley and
frankly it happened without my awareness
that there was going to be a protest but
I happened to be nearby and I was
sympathetic and so I joined it and I was
coming down the street with the protest
and the cop hit me with a with a baton
knocked me down
so anyway I'm no fan of this stuff I'm
not defending it but that's not what
this movement is really about and even
if it is to the extent that it is what
this movement is really about it doesn't
deal with the root cause we're dealing
with a symptom and it's not a symptom
that you can treat in isolation well I
had Jocko will link on the podcast on
Monday and he had a great point
obviously Jocko was a Navy SEAL
commander and worked with the Navy SEALs
to create probe
for training and what he said is that
these cops have the the minimal amount
of training it's a the tiniest amount of
training and then they send them on the
street he goes twenty percent of their
time should be spent training twenty
percent it should be de-escalation
drills simulation drills educating them
on how to communicate with people in
various situations educating them as how
if one cop is in a confrontation with
someone the next cop should step in and
say let's listen Mike let's go go deal
with this over there and I'm gonna
handle this and sir let's let's let's
take this from scratch like let's work
let's work this out in that having
higher qualified police officers better
trained police officers more well better
compensated police forces so they're not
taxed out is really the answer to all
this and these people are there you know
nobody wants to be a cop right now so
who's doing this right who's the new
generation from now out when when people
sign up to be a police officer who's
gonna do this it's a you have a few that
are gonna answer that call because they
feel like it's they have a duty but
you're gonna have a lot of people that
just they can't get other jobs and so
they choose that and maybe they're not
the cream of the crop and so that's very
bad for people with guns that tell other
people what to do I hear two things in
what you're saying and one of them I
fully agree with the implication what
you just said is that less funding isn't
the solution if anything more funding is
so that we get better qualified people
better training trained them right we
get people who are better suited to the
job in the first place and then we train
them better so they know what to do and
I agree with that the part that I'm
worried about is that I also I think I
hear you grasping at straws and frankly
they're familiar I hear everybody
grasping at straws here and what I think
is not getting said is that brutal
policing is a feature not a bug all
right this is part of a system that is
about something else and to the extent
that I think we can all recognize that
there is something absolutely organic
about the anger that has caused people
to spill into the streets in large
numbers that anger is the result of a
process that does not begin with
policing it begins with
economic phenomena and political
phenomena and one of the things that
spooks me is this movement in part
because it is leaderless and I would
argue rudderless it is not correctly
addressing the actual problem it is
lashing out at things that it can see
it's lashing out in anecdotes but the
only solution here the only proper
solution that actually saves the
Republic is a solution that addresses
the core problem economic despair
communities that are filled with crime
and violence and gangs and the people
that come out of these communities with
very little hope and all the models that
they operate under the what what they
model themselves on is what they see
around them which is all this crime and
they they don't have this sense that
there's a very clear path out of this
well let's um I want to step back to
something that will sound too remote to
be useful but I'm sure it isn't I would
claim that this actually goes back to a
shift in the Democratic Party during the
Clinton administration during the
Clinton administration the Democratic
Party effectively switched it took up
the Republican Party's business model
moving away from defending the interests
of common people as its reason for
gaining power and that created a problem
so during the Clinton administration we
saw the end to aid with family to
families with dependent children we saw
NAFTA we saw basically an abandonment of
the core resin d'etre for the Democratic
Party now the Republican Party at that
point was the party of business but that
doesn't really mean the party of
business what the Republican Party was
was the party of well-established large
businesses which frequently meant as it
was catering to their interests that it
was preventing small businesses from
rising up that would threaten its
constituents now the Democrats took up
this model they went into influence
peddling as well during the Clinton
administration and they became the party
of other businesses so now you have two
parties that are basically dealing with
competing business interests vying for
power but what that does is
excludes the interests of regular folks
and so regular folks have been getting
the shaft ever since nobody is
representing their interests they're
getting wise to it and they're feeling
the effects on the street they are
feeling the system is rigged it's rigged
against them
it's not even evenly rigged against them
so you know in black communities there's
a perception it's specifically rigged
against us and you know what it is but
the way it is is very subtle right it's
not a matter of racism being ubiquitous
you know inside every white head it's
not like that this has very little to do
with modern racism but what it has to do
with is a property of our system so you
know there's a cybernetic principle the
purpose of a system is what it does it
means that don't listen to what somebody
says that the system is for look at what
it accomplishes that's what it's for and
our system basically has two things that
it accomplishes it basically keeps real
change from happening and the reason it
keeps real change from happening is
because people who are winning in the
present system will continue to win if
the system continues to do what it does
and they may lose if the system changes
and starts doing something else so it
creates what I would argue is a kind of
organic conservatism those with power
don't want change because it threatens
them and the other thing that our system
does is it reproduces present patterns
of distribution into the future and what
that means is racism that has almost
died out is still alive and well in a
sense
because all you have to do is take
people who are born into a neighborhood
that is devoid of opportunity and
continue that pattern if no opportunity
shows up then people who were oppressed
are now going to continue to be
oppressed and so it feels personal but
it isn't it's just reproducing an
existing pattern and a lot of that
emanates from these communities that
have been disenfranchised and
economically distraught from slavery
like literally from that where we're
dealing with the echoes of slavery and
it doesn't get addressed and when people
do bring it up and they start talking
about rep
nation's people roll their eyes and
people go oh so long ago but the results
of that are still alive today in the
South they're still alive today in many
communities that were redlined as
recently as the 1960s right that's
exactly right
and so it we basically have set
ourselves up for a confused response
because there is a subtlety the fact
that ancient races and people who are
dead their racism still haunts us today
through mechanisms of the reproduction
of patterns of distribution and mind you
and people here distribution they freak
out because they think you're talking
about wealth I'm not talking about
wealth and we can talk about why I
wouldn't bother but what we're talking
about is opportunity opportunity has
been hoarded it has been concentrated in
some zip codes and almost totally
excluded from other zip codes
and so you're right the patterns of
slavery moved into Jim Crow and now
they've moved into a phase where they
are very subtly infused in into our
system and so it is causing people to
have the sense that there is an enemy
and it is out to get me when it's not
exactly an enemy that's out to get you
it's a pattern right it's a pattern that
definitely needs to be addressed and so
the natural place would have been the
Democratic Party but the Democratic
Party because it has taken up with big
business is not going to do it even
though it would be a winning political
strategy the Democratic Party is more
interested in serving the political the
economic interests of its actual
constituents than it is serving the
interests of its nominal constituents
and so why are you seeing something that
looks like a communist revolution
beginning in the streets for the natural
reason which is that people are feeling
excluded from from their share and they
are being excluded but this revolution
that is beginning in our streets is no
more coherent or desirable than you know
then Maoism and it's going to be brutal
in in the Maoist way or possibly the way
that it unfolded in the French
Revolution or maybe it'll be some you
know unique version and it'll get its
own name
but if we want the Republic to survive
we're gonna have to prevent this from
happening and because it's a leaderless
movement who do you even talk to
who'd be reasonable yeah that's what's
fascinating about it right because it's
emerging not just in America but it's
also in England it's and it's in all
parts of the world people are protesting
and in many ways I think that's it's
probably because loved it or hated
America sort of takes the cultural lead
for the world in a lot of ways when it
comes to movements and particularly art
and and and you know expression and I
see this leaderless movement and it
seems so attractive to young people that
do feel disenfranchised by the system so
I I watch them I mean I've seen so many
videos of these people out there
screaming and cheering and chanting and
they feel like they're a part of
something right and they are right but
what is that thing that they're a part
of like what's the end goal that doesn't
seem to have been really clear like
there's kids out in they were out in
Woodland Hills out there chanting no
justice no peace and I'm like okay what
justice you talking about are you
talking about George Floyd well that in
that case it seems like that guy's gonna
go to jail for the rest of his life and
I don't know if that's justice or not
that police department has been
disbanded I don't know if that's justice
or not but what is justice and what is
peace it's just a slogan but they feel
good saying it no justice no peace but
what I don't know what you're saying but
you feel very passionate about what
you're saying and I I think if you
pulled one of those kids aside and said
what's your message and what are you
trying to do I think a lot of them would
have nothing to say and that's what's
that's very concerning to me I'm very
concerned about that because it seems
like they're very enthusiastic and
passionate about an invisible enemy and
an enemy that they can't they can't put
on a scale they can't tangibly describe
it in a way that I understand it
completely it just seems like the
structure of things they feel like is is
unjust it is unfortunately a zombified
collective fighting a boogeyman that
they have invented which again doesn't
mean that their frustration is not about
something very real that does require a
solution but to the extent that these
people have D individuated and they've
become a true mob and they are pushing
policies that make no sense and endanger
us all I mean there is no neighborhood
in the u.s. that is going to be safer
for the absence of the police and it
really doesn't even matter how corrupt
the police are the absence of the police
is going to create a power vacuum and
we're going to get warlords as we're
already seeing in miniature in Seattle
as we already saw it evergreen yeah so
it's not a coherent proposal but I have
a concern that the reason that this is
leaderless is that something that I
think is unrelated I really think it's
unintentional but there is something
about the way that influence happens in
this era that has taken all of the
would-be leaders and it has trapped them
in the gig economy and so we have a lot
of people who would be in an excellent
position to steer this justifiable anger
at an enemy that is actually worth
attacking to curb the violence and to
make this a a moment of useful and
necessary change I would argue overdue
change
but those people are instead of being
leaders but they are as influencers and
influencers don't have the kind of power
necessary to shape a movement and they
don't have the position to negotiate on
its behalf and this is very dangerous
where do you think this escalates to do
you have a map in your mind of where the
territory is yeah I mean I would say
there are several ways it could go but
unfortunately the dynamics look almost
unresolvable if somebody does not speak
for the movement and with it being
unresolvable you've got a conflict
between rural people and urban people
you
a conflict between blacks and those who
are self declared allies and Ally
doesn't really mean a lie but foot
soldiers on behalf of this movement and
people who won't go along with it and
what I'm trying to raise people's
awareness of right now is that there's
something in us being raised in the u.s.
there's something in us that thinks that
the Great Leap Forward in China cannot
happen here that what happened in
Cambodia cannot happen here that Nazi
Germany cannot happen right and you know
the Soviet Union couldn't happen here I
don't know what characteristic it is
that people think makes it impossible I
don't think it's impossible I think if
there is a characteristic that makes it
unlikely it is the structure it is the
Constitution which I would argue is
showing its age but nonetheless the
values that America aspires to the
reason that the world does pay attention
to us and still even with all of our
brokenness allows us to lead it that
reason is that the values that were
described were honorable even if they
even if we didn't meet them but what we
aspired to be was great and I you know I
resent Trump's make America great again
because there are populations for whom
it has simply never been great right so
I think that last a in Magga is just a
finger in the eye for people and it was
designed to be but the structure what it
aspires to be as great and heading in
the direction in which it could be great
for everybody is obviously the right
thing to do but what we are now doing
and the thing that troubles me most
about this movement is that if you
listen to it closely and I have listened
to it very closely it is explicitly
about disassembling the very things that
make the West marvelous right it is anti
science right it does not want policy
based on science in fact it's also well
I mean you saw last week presumably that
it got nature the journal Nature Science
magazine
Caltech it got all of these just
absolutely top-level scientific
institutions to broadcast the hashtag
shutdown stem what oh yeah no I'm not
aware of this at all
oh well and this is another thing we're
losing our minds because to me the idea
that you would be unaware of this is
hard to imagine because this is so much
going on
it was so thoroughly all over my feed
though but I'm discovering this there's
stuff absent from my feed to that I
should know about
and I'm finding the same thing but
here's the thing yeah I don't read my
feet
well you don't read your Twitter feed
but you're plugged into enough people
your conversations in this room things
have to be like almost nuclear before
I'm paying attention to them these days
just for my own personal sanity yeah I
I've stepped away from almost all social
media other than posting yeah it's
actually I can say something perfectly
weird
I don't really aspire to great wealth I
never have but there is part of me that
wants to be wealthy enough that I can
afford to ignore my feeds right I can't
now I have plugged in but but anyway the
the thing that is really concerning here
and I you know I I don't want this
podcast to be all about concern there's
thousands of scientists go on strike to
protest systemic racism and stem more
than 5,000 scientists and two prominent
scientific journals shut down operations
and pledged to use the day to address
racial inequalities in science the
strike follows two weeks of
demonstrations spurred by the police
killing of George Floyd a black man who
died after a white police officer put
people on social media are spreading
word about the strike with the hashtag
shut down academia mmm-hmm shut down
stem and strike for black lives shut
down academia is terrifying
shut down stem is equally terrifying but
I mean like what takes its place what do
you expect well if you shut down
academia like what do they what are they
saying when they say systemic racism and
stem what does it mean it's
representation in terms of like the what
are they saying so this is so sad
because truly if you if you really
wanted to
to raise black people out of the
quagmire the economic quagmire they find
themselves in if you wanted to do it on
mass you would arm them with the most
powerful tools all right the most
powerful tool and the tool that is best
positioned to address biases especially
subtle biases is science that's that's
what the scientific method does that's
it's one reason for existing is that it
takes that which you think and allows
you to see why it is wrong right it
takes your biases and forces you to see
what's wrong with them that's what
science is for now the reason that this
movement is attacking stem has to do
with the connection of this movement to
critical theory and critical theory
didn't come from the science as the word
theory is basically pilfered right it's
being used in the most ironic fashion
critical theory is a narrative that's
now becoming a religious movement and it
is anti stem on the basis that it claims
that stem itself science itself is
racist inherently what do they mean when
they say where they're saying critical
theory yeah what does that encompass
well my understanding is that critical
theory was born as an honorable
investigation of biases that exist
inside of our court system racial biases
and that it has now morphed into
something that its originators don't
recognize and don't respect that it has
become basically I mean you know you've
had Jordan Peterson on your podcast many
times once with me and you know he what
he talks about with respect to these
these are cultural Marxists and they are
wielding this postmodern doctrine but
he's talking about his critical theory
right critical theory is basically a a
Trojan horse that exists in academic
departments that are dedicated to its
study and what it does is it uninvent
progress in other fields and that's a
very uninteresting process when it's
hiding away in some corner of your
university where you don't have to
listen to it but what has happened is it
has now reached enough people that it
has spilled out into public and the
nonsense that you hear
shutting down academia shutting down
stem abolishing the police all of this
is standard fare in those phony
departments when you say uninvent
progress now what do you mean by that
well I mean that we have a system and
you know I'm as upset about what doesn't
work about it as anybody but we have a
system that accomplishes a great deal
and this style of thought that all of
these departments that end in theory
that don't actually function by normal
rules of logic or the scientific process
these things are an attack there like an
autoimmune disease of the academic
culture and by and large the scientific
part of the Academy keeps his head down
and it stays away from people who
believe in this stuff and it tries to do
its work but what has happened is that
the dynamics the demographics have
changed such that these departments
which weren't taken seriously by the
sciences are now dictating terms to the
sciences which couldn't possibly be more
dangerous because to the extent that the
the argument more or less is that the
sciences are unfairly biased in favor of
those who are currently successful and
that that bias is actually preventing
people who are not succeeding under
current conditions from getting there
and therefore we need to hobble these
disciplines to level the playing field
well imagine that America surrendered
its advantage in the sciences in order
to even if you could level the playing
field inside of the US by doing that
which you can't but even if you could
this would so hobble us in the world
that it would be an insane policy to
pursue is there any debate going on
about this clearly what they're saying
is if you're looking at the vast
majority of the scientists they
represent but what is it european jews
are a lot of them there's a lot of
various people of European ancestry
Asian folks less African Americans less
Africans so they're saying that
because of this this is clear this is
clear evidence of racism yeah when is
total nonsense
what is it evidence of it is well it's
evidence of a number of things and you
know I find myself in two places on a
lot of these arguments on the one hand
somehow I'm sitting here on your podcast
defending academia when on any normal
day I would be telling you academia was
so incredibly broken and science has
been so incredibly incredibly corrupted
by its contact with the market that we
have to fix these things because that is
in and of itself a threat you know to
the West here I find myself saying wait
a second these people are actually
telling you what they think they think
science is the enemy and instead of
democratizing the tools of science and
giving them to the people who need the
most they want to end science so the
problems are several unfortunately
they're not tremendously interesting
they're sort of dry inside baseball
stuff but we I think we have to cover
them though just to sort of take the
legs out from under this racism argument
when it comes to representation sure so
first of all let me just say academia is
tremendously liberal and that I mean
that in both senses let's take the
Honorable part of it right inside of a
university there is every desire to
bring people who do not look like the
old white guys that have done so much of
the past work in science there is a
desire to to broaden you know so it is
not true that privately scientists are
harboring racist views and talking about
them and then you know behaving
themselves when they're around people
who are of a different color it's not
like that
okay there is a desire to have those
people show up and get the job because
for one thing it takes the pressure off
to the extent that departments don't
look like the demographics of the
country in which these departments are
housed you know that raises questions
and so there's a desire to bring in
anybody who makes it clear that that's
not going on however let's say that you
were you were black and you grew up in a
neighborhood where the odds were stacked
against you
and you made it let's say that um you
know you had people who said wise things
to you and they got you to focus on the
right stuff and you managed to dodge the
stuff that captures so many and you made
it right let's say you got into Harvard
you got a really good quality degree in
a in a in a proper science well what are
you gonna do with it you're gonna go
into academia that would be insane
because I don't know what the numbers
are I don't know what fraction of people
who get PhDs actually get the job that
they've trained for but it's tiny really
I'll be like one in twenty really yeah
because there's only so many positions
and every year you're graduating
hundreds and hundreds of people with
those degrees well but there's also a
very good reason for this I mean it's a
terrible reason but there's a very
easily comprehended reason so
universities are fueled in large measure
by what's called overhead of the grants
so if you get a million dollar grant
half or more will go to your university
right so that's what builds the
buildings and fuels to place so the
university has an incentive to get as
many people file grant applications as
they can and they have an incentive to
hire people whose grant applications
will be large rather than small so this
for example is one of the reasons that
science has taken up arms against theory
that is to say proper scientific
theoreticians like me and it is instead
hired people who run big expensive
experiments because big expensive
experiments have big grants and those
big grants bring in money but if you
were a university and what you wanted
was to have people writing big expensive
grants who were capable of getting them
then what you would want to do is you
would want to free those people from
teaching and you would want to get
people who weren't so expensive to do
the work of the university and the way
you do that is you bring them on as
graduate students and you pay them an
appalling wage you claim you claim that
they are not actually workers that their
students and they they do most of the
teaching and they do a lot of the work
of the university for incredibly low
amounts of money they live under poor
conditions and increasingly they have to
come from abroad
where
in some sense getting a deal that still
makes sense but this means that we over
produce PhDs we give people degrees
instead of money to do the work of the
university in order that the people who
are capable of getting the grant spend
almost full time doing that job and it's
a racket mmm so in that what I wasn't
aware of that at all I didn't know how
it works yeah it's a racket and and the
person you should talk to the person who
knows the most about this is actually
Eric my brother mhm so what he unearthed
was actually that there was an explicit
conspiracy to game the visa system in
order to keep the system running that in
fact effectively a fake shortage of
science students was created to allow
the universities to basically flood the
market to drive the wages down but all
of these things mean that if you are
coming from circumstances that have been
challenging and you make it you don't
want to go to graduate school in the
sciences because it's a dumb move you're
going to take having gotten your head
above water and then you're gonna
voluntarily drown and it doesn't make
any sense you're much better off even as
bad as you know being a doctor has
become it used to be a great job now
it's kind of a sucky job but you're
better off doing that because at least
it's a job you'll pay off your loans
you know you'll make it and so basically
what we see is that there are lots of
reasons that a rational person from
certain demographics is less likely to
go into the sciences that's not racism
in the sciences it's again one of these
echoes of a past racism or a past
indifference that is having huge impact
on the present okay so these people that
want to that think that stem is racist
and they want to dismantle it what do
they propose like what what do they
propose a replacement of stem and
academia so I'm what they want is so
strange and preposterous that it damages
my credibility to even say it I will I
will answer your question okay but I
know that what I'm saying sounds
preposterous so the only reason that
so certain of it is that I've talked to
them directly and I watched this happen
at every talk to them correct directly
so you know this is actually what they
want well I can't say they because or
undoubtedly there's variation but I can
say that to the extent that I've
actually had these conversations with
people I was left completely shocked by
you know there was an it there was an
example at Evergreen where we were in a
faculty meeting and I said that the
proposals that were moving through were
a threat to the Enlightenment values
that were the basis of the institution
and what I got back was something I had
never heard before which was an attack
not only on the enlightenment but on the
idea of enlightenment I was just so
stunned I was a college professor
amongst faculty and somebody was
actually saying out loud that
enlightenment was a problem and nobody
in the room said anything what did they
mean by enlightenment as a problem well
so here's here's what I say to two
people who asked me about this students
in particular the Enlightenment was a
European project right it definitely had
a light skin tone right it was it was
European men it was not a Jewish project
but I am NOT embarrassed about taking
the tools of the Enlightenment and
wielding they don't belong to Europe
right they're human they're human tools
they were a discovery in Europe and
arguably the discovery in Europe
happened because of unfair exclusion of
other people but at some level who the
[ __ ] cares those are the most powerful
tools ever and you you can't uninvent
them the thing to do is distribute them
as broadly as possible mm-hmm but if
you're in critical theory first of all
if you end up in critical theory any one
of these fields women's studies queer
studies whatever it is you have already
foregone this option you don't end up in
critical theory if you have the chops to
do science
so in effect you have people who don't
stand to personally benefit from opening
those doors wider because they wouldn't
go through them arguing that nobody
should go through those doors so let's
take a sidestep here
critical theory when you're talking
about gender studies or queer studies or
why do you think those are not valid
avenues for people to pursue well
because the method is non-existent if
you were to do these things properly you
would study them with the tools of stem
right but we know from we know that's
not what goes on inside of these
departments and we also know that the
product doesn't add up from the point of
view of science you can't take the claim
for example that if a man decides that
he is a woman then he is a woman it's
not a valid claim it just doesn't stand
up and you can't claim that sex is a
spectrum either
that claim doesn't stand up these are
empty and we could have a discussion
about what we are to do in light of the
part of gender that is flexible but
we're not having that conversation
because we've got an ultimatum on the
table either you agree sex is a spectrum
or you're the enemy
so all I would say is just empirically
this is what happens now I will also say
one of the most telling incidents that
happened during the evergreen riots is
now finally it's been covered by PBS
I've talked about it on my podcast a
student of Heather and mine an excellent
student one of the best ones we ever had
as a young woman named Odette
Odette is half black
her mom is afro-caribbean she was known
to be my student and heather student
during the riots and she was actually
confronted and physically bullied by the
rioters who accused her of being a race
traitor for studying science this
actually happened and what I'm telling
you what did they say when
say you're a race traitor for studying
science what what's what specific
discipline well she was studying
evolutionary biology with Heather and me
and and they said you were a race
traitor for studying evolutionary
biology because because science is
racist it's nonsense and I hear you're
trying to parse it as if it makes sense
and I think they don't understand as a
person who spent three years barely
paying attention in college I don't know
how it got to that I don't know how that
becomes an actual course I don't know
how that gets funded I don't know how
that you can get a degree from that well
so what I've heard of late and I'm it
may be James Lindsay who is the
originator of of this phraseology but
there's a term racism of the gaps and
racism of the gaps is a reference to the
God of the gaps hypothesis anything we
can't explain in science is explained by
God which is obviously nonsense but
racism of the gap says any place where
that we see a success differential the
explanation is inherently racism so if
we see an absence of black people in
math obviously the answer is racist do
they apply that in areas where black
people excel no because this is a self
serving modality like hip hop right and
so let's go back to a debt for a second
trying to parse what they're saying as
if it has content logical content is a
mistake mm-hmm trying to parse it as a
tactical move makes a lot of sense okay
let's imagine that Odette was not the
courageous person that she is and that
she had caved right imagine you're
cornered you know you're alone you've
got a mob that's actually physically
confronting you for studying science if
she was not a person of strong character
she might have signed up with them if
she had signed up with them then eh now
they have a potentially powerful ally
right a black person former student of
or at that point I guess current student
of Heather in mine
who would say yes in fact science is
racist evolutionary biology particularly
so I was in that class yada yada yada
and people are easily influenced and
that man being bullied by that would
probably cause a lot of people to cave
in to that and give in to that just for
conformity just so the people who accept
them yes and so thank goodness that
Odette is somebody who is of incredibly
strong character who really got the
message of evolutionary biology very
deeply and there is nothing that they
could have said or threatened her with
it would have caused her to make the
move that they wanted her to make but
processing it tactically is important
what they're doing is tactical and what
they did with shut down stem tactical
they were proving their power right they
were able to get the most important
scientific institutions to broadcast a
demand to shut down stem that's an
amazing level of power and actual
scientists that are in disciplines that
are legit like evolutionary biology went
along with them well you know I
contacted Richard Dawkins as this was
happening
hmm because I didn't see anything on his
feed that suggested you know he hadn't
made a statement I thought it would be
powerful him to do for him to do it he
was totally unaware of what's going on
right so you have the most important
institutions broadcasting this thing
something about our environment is not
calling it to the attention of people
who might be in a position to say
something and the whole thing is it's
setting us up we're in we're in
tremendous danger and what what do you
think their motivation is power power
well again what happens we'll get
through they shut down stem then what do
they do how you know did they are they
thinking this far ahead they're not
playing this long game um okay I would
just I would tell people who aren't
aware of me and what I think and believe
that I am very progressive I am very
interested in making a fair system as a
my cousin line I know you I know you are
so what I'm about to say sounds like one
of those right-wing crazy things what
they want well
imagine the following look first of all
let's talk about reparations for a
second okay okay
I am NOT a fan of the idea of
reparations I think it would be a
terrible failure it would be a disaster
but I do believe that something of very
substantial magnitude is justified I
just don't think reparations is the
answer I completely agree okay
I think reform in terms of communities I
think spending massive amounts of money
to rebuild communities and give people
hope yes economic opportunities massive
investment communities that have been
systematically frozen out and I put I
would put American blacks and American
Indians at the top of the list because I
believe they have a special claim is a
particular vehicles are particularly
distraught because they've been
subjugated to this weird position when
they're stuck on these reservations so
we'll come back to this maybe but I
think that there's something very
special that happened with blacks and
with Indians yeah or not it's not
exactly alike but it has to do with
their different origin stories that
these two populations have both suffered
a parallel I don't even know what to
call it an obstacle yeah that doesn't it
makes them unlike anyone other America
yes yes so not in favor of reparations
but I would be in favor of something
that did the job that reparations are
imagined to do okay what this movement
is is an attempt to create a slant in
every single interaction that does the
job of reparations its reparations 24
hours a day seven days a week
in every room in every institution in
every context right now that will be the
uninvented of America it is in some
weird sense a mirror for the America
that blacks and Indians have faced they
have faced an America in which
everything was slanted against them it
has grown less so but again we have the
echoes of that deeply slanted America
that are broadcasting to the present at
a high level of intensity but
you cannot do reparations inside of
every institution every hour every
discussion that is not a plausible plan
even people who support the idea of
monetary reparations of the solution if
they understood the dynamics of trying
to infuse it into every interaction
there is no way it could possibly work
and it invalidates all of the most
important principles on which America
runs so we are really talking about
uninvent in America and substituting a
reparations program for it which it just
couldn't possibly be a bigger hazard and
think think for a second if you're
trying to imagine what the hell I'm
talking about mm-hmm imagine the courts
right now there is a problem there's a
process called jury nullification and
Eric has pointed out that jury
nullification is a huge hazard in an era
where people are saying as much nonsense
about who's guilty and who's innocent
and what it has to do with race as we
have because effectively you can
instantly create a situation in which
the law doesn't apply to certain folks
because of the color of their skin right
that would be an advantage you could
argue that it was compensatory for years
of being on the other end of that deal
but it cannot be made to function but
the other thing is also possible right
you can not only have the law not apply
to people on the basis that they have a
skin color that suggests they've had a
raw deal but you can also make the law
apply to people because of their skin
color we can have show trials right I
was effectively exposed to the
equivalent of a show trial at Evergreen
right I was convicted of racism and it
happened that for various reasons I knew
damn well that the charge was completely
empty based on my history as a human
being and so I felt I could stand up to
it and withstand it and I guess in a way
I did on the other hand my wife and I
were driven out of the college so yes I
survived it but I didn't survive it
intact right I made it somewhere else
but that show trial mentality I mean it
would be a perfect fit for the the
maoist part of this
of this movements ethos I mean we're
already seeing struggle sessions people
being forced to admit things that aren't
true right do you think part of the part
of the influence of this is that we
particularly white Americans realize
that there's a significant difference
there's a significant disparity between
opportunity that people in these
disenfranchised communities of color
have versus us there's a difference and
so when someone from these critical
theory disciplines should I even say
discipline some lack of discipline when
they promote this people that are in
recognition that there is a problem in
this country there is a situation this
country and to voice any sort of
disagreement with this movement that
seems to represent the idea that there
is a problem you you become a part of of
racism so in order to stand out as not
being racist
you are literally abandoning the ideas
of science you're abandoning all this
just so that you don't get labeled on
the wrong side of history yes and I was
alerted to something a few days ago that
I was not aware of which is it's gonna
sound far afield but what I ran into was
somebody describing what had happened to
American POWs in the Korean War who were
being administered by the Chinese the
Chinese had a very sophisticated
mechanism for basically brainwashing and
the mechanism was something that I have
seen in this movement but didn't
understand had a formal history when
always imagines brainwashing to be this
very aggressive thing but the
incremental nosov the move that was
arranged for these POWs was the key
feature so the first thing that
apparently POWs were asked to do
was to write essays it was really
important that they write it rather than
just say it but that they write essays
on topics that any reasonable person
would think was fair like America is not
perfect right you could write that essay
I can write did I say there's no moral
compromise in write that essay or the
other example was you know unemployment
is not a problem under communism okay
that doesn't strike me as a bridge too
far communism has lots of problems but
maybe that's not one of them
so people were marched from these very
tiny concessions we're really the
concession was just
you're gonna write what I tell you right
rather than any part of the content to
an absolutely massive shift in their
understanding and along the way they
were
for example induced to to write more
substantial concessions with some very
tiny reward like a piece of fruit or
something something that's actually
desirable and if things are scarce you
can understand wanting it but it's not
such a big concession that you can say
to yourself oh yeah I said something I
didn't believe because I got a lot out
of it so you actually talked yourself
into imagining that you really do
believe the thing you wrote you must
otherwise you wouldn't have written it
so what I'm seeing is all sorts of
excellent people making the first
concessions on two or the first steps
onto the slippery slope and it's
spooking the hell out of me so you know
I must say I saw I saw Dave Chappelle's
8:46 thing and like you I thought wow do
I get what he's saying on the other hand
I really thought he got it wrong what do
you think he got wrong
well what are you effectively said what
he effectively suggested was that he was
on board with the movement and it was
clear that this was based on his massive
frustration at how deaf the white
population has been to black suffering
which I agree with I think the white
population has been largely deaf at
least in recent decades but I don't know
how much he knows
about what the movement actually is and
what it wants in other words I have the
maximum respect for Dave Chappelle I
have for a very long time
I think he's tremendously insightful but
I don't know I mean I think he's got the
same problem tuning into the world that
everybody else does which is he gets
some slice that's fed to him or maybe
like you he is not tuned into these
things and so he gets whatever crosses
the the threshold some other way and
maybe he's not seeing that this movement
is a spouting nonsense about getting rid
of science and he's not seeing that it's
behaving in a Maoist way and he is
seeing the videos that we all see that
suggest to us that there is a very
serious problem with race-based
police brutality and the problem with
that of course is that you can't do that
analysis with anecdotes they say how
egregious they seem is it weird to
connect all those things together though
when you're saying the movement if this
movement doesn't have any leaders and
you're talking about police brutality
but you're also talking about Maoist
ideology that weasels its way into
academia is that really the same thing
is it all one thing well I don't you
know multi-headed Hydra I don't think it
is one thing but I think it's like a
coalition of things and I think each of
those things is comprehensible you know
in isolation and we can understand what
happens when you fuse them together and
all I can say is we did see this in
miniature at Evergreen and people did
say you're making too much out of it and
they were wrong and but you saw it on
the ground the problem with seeing it
from a distance is you can minimize many
things when you're you don't experience
the emotions you don't see the fear you
don't see people running through the
parking lot with baseball bats looking
for you like they were doing you know
it's a different thing when you're
actually there and you realize that this
mass hysteria does lead to pretty
despicable acts and that there is sort
of a mob mentality that grips people and
it allows people to be capable of some
pretty heinous [ __ ] and what we see here
in America
such a combination of factors right you
have Co vid which shuts everything down
so people are stuck at home for all
these months then you have this George
Floyd thing which is one of the worst
cases of police brutality I've ever seen
because it was so torturous the I I mean
if you really know how long 8 minutes
and 46 seconds is with someone leaning
on your neck you would know how [ __ ]
horrific that is and then you have the
looting yeah and then you have the mass
movement of all these people taking the
streets saying we've got to change
things we know things are wrong and on
top of that you have looting and on top
of that you have businesses failing
because of looting you have chaos people
getting their lives destroyed you have
so many things happening all together at
once to call it a a movement it don't
it's like one of the things we were
talking about with black with uh excuse
me Occupy Wall Street back in the day
was we're saying they don't seem to know
exactly what's going on but it's like
the immune system surrounding something
that's wrong like it's like something's
going on here like all these white blood
cells are flooding into this area I
forget who made that analogy it might
have been made so long ago but we're
like they don't necessarily know what to
do or what it is but they want to camp
out around that area and figure out what
the [ __ ] going on yeah and I you know
like I said at first I was on board with
this and I thought there was something
right about it and you know I even
thought the leader lessness of it was
great for two weeks and then it became
very very stupid but yeah it is an
immune reaction and that's a normal part
of history you know in revolutions are
not started by a bunch of intellectuals
who have some idea what system they want
to correct rights people who are fed up
and so that's what Dave Chappelle was
responding to and I totally get it but
the problem is we are all in danger of
being marched in the direction of things
that are anti-american that are in fact
anti black because we are trying to to
grant the right concessions on the right
points and it's a it's a case in which
you can't track what's really happening
well enough to do
surgically so I really I'm so afraid to
actually go down this next road but you
raised the case of you know George Floyd
and what we saw on that tape I want you
to think about the question of what you
actually saw on that tape and what it
actually tells you what you actually
know and what you don't know I'm worried
look best possible thing from the point
of view of the well-being of the world
would be that Derek Chauvin is guilty of
murder and he is convicted of murder and
he is sentenced for the maximum
allowable time that would be the best of
graves I'm not sure that that's actually
what is supposed to happen why is that
okay the question is did you witness a
murder are you sure you saw a murder
what do you mean by that well murder is
a crime yes okay presumably there was a
lot of complaint about the fact that
Chauvin wasn't charged with first-degree
murder
right but he didn't what story would
make it sensible that he wanted to kill
George Floyd that that was his purpose
well you know do you know that he knew
him you know he knew him in advance and
that they had had words and they had
they had had problems when they worked
together because Derek Chauvin was a
[ __ ] to customers and he was violent
to customers if he and George Floyd
worked as bouncers in the same
establishment yep and that's the that's
the the word well from the point of view
of the well-being of the world and from
the point of view of us all processing
this right in some sense I mean you know
with the understanding that there is
nothing that could possibly happen in an
investigation or in a court that's gonna
bring George Floyd back right so with
that in mind the best thing that could
happen is that he is actually guilty of
something egregious he's charged with it
he's convicted right but what do you
think that it's not murder this is what
so I'm not saying it isn't murder it may
well be murder but I'm saying that what
we saw doesn't tell us that it was
murder
why is that okay so there are several
things about what we saw what we didn't
see but now know and things that are
possible okay okay
one thing is that it appears that George
Floyd was complaining that he could not
breathe before he was on the ground okay
that he may have been having a heart
attack before he was on the ground now
again even if that's true I would think
he obviously was deserving of immediate
medical attention
and so I am NOT arguing that it would
not be criminal if he was dying of a
heart attack and that's ultimately what
killed him but what I'm saying is that
we're at the case that he was having a
heart attack he had apparently
methamphetamine and fentanyl in his
system at the time weren't the case that
he was having a heart attack
you mean same system is it was it just
because he tested positive for it or was
it active in his system was it something
that he had taken fairly recently but
the effects of it were no longer active
I'm not an expert and maybe I
misunderstood what I read but I thought
that these things were recently in his
system rather than just detected at
trace I don't know I don't know either
so let's let's leave it so again I am
NOT rooting I understand what you saw
him to be the reason why I bring that up
is coming from someone who works very
closely with the UFC and you saw one of
the things that I'm finding out is that
their methods of detection now are
insanely sensitive and you can detect
entire incredibly small non-psychoactive
amounts months and months and months
after use okay well then it's obviously
not relevant the possibility that was
having a heart attack is clearly
relevant it's possible I mean if he did
say he can't breathe it also could be
that he was struggling and there was a
tussle and he's just exhausted and he
couldn't breathe but or that reports
that he said he couldn't breathe before
he was on the ground or erroneous that's
all suppose could be a lie you wouldn't
you look at what that man did when you
look at what Derek did - George Floyd
with his knee on that man's neck I could
100% kill a man that way well okay so
here's the problem okay apparently that
technique is a technique that is
authorized by the police department in
question under some circumstances
and apparently those circumstances were
present in other words it may be that
the policy of the Minneapolis Police
Department he's a radically change no it
may be that the policy killed George
Floyd because the galaxy allowed him to
do that yeah well maybe it even required
him to do it I don't know but what the
guy wasn't resisting that's the problem
when he's on the ground he's just got
his knee on the guy's neck did you watch
the whole video I did watch the whole
thing
there's another problem with the way he
did it with there's a drain there you
see that Cement drain and his neck is
laying on the edge of the cement drain
that it's like a bone when you choke man
you know you you don't use the meaty
part of your body you use the bone and
that's essentially that divot that that
drain is laying right where his neck is
I don't know if he placed him there on
purpose yeah but I wouldn't doubt it
well I'm not saying Derrick Chauvin
didn't kill George Floyd I'm not saying
it wasn't racially motivated
I'm not saying that this wasn't murder
in the first degree based on prior
interactions I'm not saying any of that
what I'm saying is that we don't know in
the public based on what we have seen we
don't know this to have murder because
if this was Derrick Chauvin being a dick
and using the policy of the police
department and being indifferent to its
effect then that is for a court to
decide whether or not it is murder in
other words if he was right
doing the policy as the policy is laid
out based on the criteria that would
trigger the policy have you read any of
this about the policies I've read a bit
what have you read I read so it said I'm
going to struggle for the words that the
acronym stands for there is a a
situation called e XDS extreme boy I
don't have it maybe Jamie can find it
okay but again the real point here is
not that he is innocent
I don't believe him to be innocent my
real point is that we
are all acting as if we have seen with
our own eyes
something that is unambiguously murder
and I don't believe that we saw that I
believe we saw something that may well
have been murder and may well not have
been murder and that the way that we
determine whether it is murder is in the
courtroom with due process well isn't it
through autopsies because independent
autopsies did find that it's fix iation
and the cut-off of the blood supply to
the brain we're responsible for his
death now there was a police department
autopsy that was refuted by two
individual independent attorney
independent examiner's you know what you
need what you need a court you need a
court you need a court to examine the
evidence and you need it to be done in
front of a jury that is free to decide
either way and here's what I'm really
concerned about because we all think we
saw a murder right we think it's
unambiguous we think it's open and shut
right the entire case is going to unfold
in that context right and if he is
exonerated we are going to assume that
this is a miscarriage of justice yes
right which means I mean put yourself in
the position of a member of the jury if
you don't think this was murder you may
well be the person who stands in the way
of a judgement and causes who knows what
to erupt this is we're talking about
Rodney King times a thousand times a
million times a million particularly if
you look at what happened just from the
reaction to this one murder right I mean
we've seen cops murder people and we've
seen a minimal reaction by the public
just protests and people get angry this
erupted around the world nobody nobody
anticipated this or saw that but right
it speaks to the powder keg of
circumstances that we were talking about
all this different packed dynamite of
covet the lockdown financial distraught
but can we agree that it could be that
his being found not guilty would set in
motion events that could be right after
Civil War catastrophic so if that is the
case what I believe is likely to happen
is that he's likely to be
victory respective of the evidence he's
going to be sacrificed
right and you agree that that might be
for the best of everybody well what I
want to point out is that we don't
behave that way we don't behave that way
the most the center of what we are as
Americans is a country in which you are
entitled to due process in a court of
law that your guilt has to be proven
beyond a reasonable doubt and if we are
going to start sacrificing people
because there is a mob in the street
threatening to turn the place upside
down then I mean you know what that is
right
that's the uninvent of America and you
know you can't use the term lynching for
it because of the racial connotations of
that term but if we are talking about
sacrificing individuals because a mob
has decided that they are guilty then we
are in America anymore I think when you
look at the spectrum of probability if
you had a pie of is he guilty of murder
did he murder him by leaning on his neck
for eight minutes and 46 seconds or did
he not I would say did he not is so
small you would have to have a [ __ ]
magnifying glass to look at it if I am
I'm an expert on choking people you know
I understand what happens to the brain
when you cut off the blood supply I've
had it done to me what that guy is doing
is torture and I think I could I know I
could kill a man that way I know I could
yeah if I if I decided to lean on
someone's neck for eight minutes and 46
seconds with all my weight that's a dead
person there's no way you're gonna
survive all right if your neck one side
of your neck is on the concrete and the
other side is 200 pounds of my body all
focused on my knee and I'm balancing my
weight on your neck you're a dead man
okay so that's what we saw well III I
know what you're saying that maybe he
also had a heart attack but the idea
that those two are not related seems to
me to be outside of the realm of
possibility so I wanna I want to make a
trade with you okay
okay I absolutely hope that you're right
okay I hope this is clear but in
exchange for that I want the agreement
that the American thing to do is to
convict him by the evidence in a court
of law
and if the evidence is not sufficiently
compelling that's not what's supposed to
happen that that would be unamerican for
that to be the way he was convinced and
we are convicting him in the court of
public opinion but we're doing it based
on a video of a man putting all his
weight on this guy's neck for eight
minutes and forth doesn't mean when you
roll in jiu-jitsu class generally rolls
between five minutes maybe 10 minutes or
something like that and the idea of a
man being on my neck the entire time is
[ __ ] terrifying
oh I believe I saw a tremendous
miscarriage of justice what I don't know
and what I don't think any of us
understand is what is the policy did he
exceed the policy did he enact the
policy I just can't imagine what his cop
would think that that was the way to do
it it's one thing if someone is
resisting arrest and they're very
dangerous and you're handcuffing them
and you put your knee on your neck on
their neck to hold them down in place
and I think that is a valid move if
you've got a guy and he's got a gun or
he's wired on PCP and he's very strong
and there's a bunch of you trying to
hold on to the guy and someone leans on
his neck I'm all for that but then when
you're done when you got him cuffed let
him go there's not a threat that guy
wasn't even moving I want to be begging
for his life I wanted George Floyd to be
taken to a hospital it seems clear to me
that he needed to be taken to a hospital
but I don't know okay here we go sir can
also use two type of neck restraints in
less severe circumstances one is called
conscious neck restraint which is an
officer applies light to moderate
pressure to the side of a person's neck
but does not intend to knock a person
unconscious that could be used against
people who are actively resisting so
that alone just dismisses this whole
idea because that's not what was going
on there that guy was not actively
resistant the other neck restraint is
one meant to render someone unconscious
that could be used when someone is
exhibiting active aggression and for
life-saving purposes again this does not
apply
department policy said neck restraints
can't be used against people who are
passively resisting so right there it
says neck has changed should not have
been used against George Floyd because
he was not violently resisting that's
not what was going on he was not
exhibiting a great active aggression
well doesn't do that he was begging for
his life he was calling out for his dead
mother's mother I know Sallie rific [ __ ]
I am feeling the need to emphasize I do
believe I saw a miscarriage of justice
but I know that the American thing to do
is to have all of this out in a court of
law where all of the appropriate
arguments are on the table I agree with
you I don't I don't see a way where he
wasn't guilty but I do agree with you
that he should be tried in a court of
law but but it's based on that I say
he's guilty and then we're also looking
at the comparison between the Eric
Gardner case which I also thought was
horrible and I also said as a person
who's an expert in martial arts
that was a chokehold they were saying it
wasn't chokehold that was a chokehold
but here's the thing about the Eric
Gardner case they should have never
[ __ ] arrested that guy in the first
place he was just selling loose
cigarettes like what kind of a world
we're living in we grabbed a guy by his
neck because he's selling loose
cigarettes and when those guys did
tackle him and take him down to the
ground and held on him when he said he
can't breathe he also appeared to be in
poor health and it was likely that the
altercation which probably wouldn't have
killed you killed him and it was awful
terrible but this was a hundred times
worse well can we come you say what kind
of a world are we living in where
somebody selling loose cigarettes has
this kind of interaction and yeah we can
say the same thing for George Floyd
right we're talking about yeah
counterfeit $20 bills nothing yeah right
but I want to go back to what I said
before police brutality is a feature not
a bug yes I agree with you so what I
mean by that is if you are going to
freeze people out of their share of the
well-being that is generated by society
you are going to have to keep them from
revolting and so what you do is you set
up some sort of arbitrary administrator
of authority that people run in count
with that they fear right you set up
some force that disincentivizes
misbehavior and that force isn't just
the police it's obviously the the the
prison system as well here's where I'd
argue with you about that
okay that is that only applies if you
only see that force exhibited towards
poor people and disenfranchised
communities but you don't what you see
with police brutality is you see police
brutality being utilized on wealthy
people if they don't know you you see if
they don't know that they can't get away
with it do you know the case of the the
young man that was killed in hotel in
Arizona
of course yeah it was horrific horrific
in on video this guy being forced to
crawl on the ground by this cop and then
the cop shoots him in the back because
he's trying to reach to pull his pants
up yep there's no threat right clearly
no threat no weapon no nothing is you've
got a monster who just wants to [ __ ]
shoot people and I think it points to
what Jocko was saying a lack of training
a lack of quality people and a lack of a
process of weeding out people that would
be more inclined to use police brutality
and that process I think should be
similar to buds like what Navy SEALs
have to go through or Rangers have to go
through and it should be something that
weeds out people of weak character so
the police should be something that's a
very difficult job to get well you only
get the cream of the crop of human
beings of character of emotional
stability people that would not do
something like that who would recognize
that man on the ground as being a father
and a husband and a human being is a
part of our community and you don't gun
them down just because you're a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and that's what that guy
did well so it's not just a bug that's
designed to keep people of
disenfranchised communities from
speaking out and demanding their fair
share it's a bug of human beings who
have power over other human beings it's
when you know the Stanford Prison
Experiment of course experiments which
of course have been sort of discredited
in some ways that they actually probably
wanted out of it so they expect but the
idea behind it makes sense to us that if
you give people power over people they
kind of tend to abuse it
people have just unchecked authority
over folks they tend to they tend to use
that it's a it's a feature of human
beings Oh believe me I mean like I said
before I only told you the the simpler
story of my run-in with the cops right I
know that that putting a badge on
somebody and giving them a weapon and
giving them all of that power it brings
the worst out in many people and it's
very very it's very dangerous yes but I
still I still see something systemic
here that isn't being discussed I don't
think we disagree on that
I think that's there as well I think
there's multiple factors well multiple
factors yes but let's put it this way my
claim is that opportunity is being
hoarded right at the top of the economic
ladder opportunity is widespread you can
do very well the further you get down
the economic ladder the less opportunity
there is and the greater the danger of
you are falling off the bottom right in
some communities you start off off the
bottom yes and you cannot access the
ladder up in such cases it is not
surprising that people resort to crime
the reason most yeah do not resort to
crimes that they have better options
right or wired to pick better options so
let's talk about a couple things okay
and I do hope we get to some science at
some point we got a lot of time brother
good all right so let's talk for a
second about why the black community has
a special problem in America can we talk
about that sure all right so I want to
talk about two things one has to do with
the special origin story for the African
derived population of Americans
obviously slavery is where most African
Americans come from they arrived through
that mechanism but slavery has a special
interaction with the normal structures
of being a human being
all right so a human being is sort of a
generalist creature with a capacity to
have its
software reworked for different habitats
the reason that human beings are able to
exploit every terrestrial habitat where
plants grow is that they don't all have
the software program that's the same
right you can have a software program
for hunting in the Kalahari you can have
one for terracing the Andes to grow
potatoes you can have any one of a
number of software programs well slavery
took the software program that Africans
who were brought into the slave trade
had and it did its best to erase that
program and to render that program
non-functional it rendered it
non-functional by combining people from
different places who didn't even
necessarily speak a language so there
was not one culture available and it
sort of forces the bootstrapping of a
new culture which was composed of
various things but of course there was a
you know prohibition against teaching
slaves to read and things like that so
there was a systematic breaking of the
original culture that Africans had we
were in the new world and a substituting
of a version that was not as much of a
threat to the slaveholding population
right and at the point that slavery
comes to an end it is not as if frankly
even we you know we didn't even have the
tools to talk about these things in
responsible terms it wasn't enough known
about how the mind works and what its
relationship is to the to the body and
also the the thing that makes the black
population and the Indian population
different I would argue is the
systematic hobbling of the on board the
inherited evolved culture in the case of
Indians by transporting them to two
reservations and by putting them in
schools that disrupt the passage of
normal culture and in the case of
Africans it was you know breaking a part
of families keeping people from being in
contact with others whom they had the
right language to talk to and all so in
any case that carries through to the
present it creates a situation where
there has not been access to the
materials to fully bring to fully update
software am i making sense yes yes okay
you're speaking about this almost purely
from organ evolutionary biology
perspective
yes I'm and I'm afraid that it's not
it's not probably going to come through
what I'm saying is that when you have
one population in control of how another
population accesses the shared culture
that it's never fair right and so we saw
this with you know conquistadores who
came into the new world and were forcing
catholicism on the inca for example
right so there's this there's always
this attempt to to hand off culture that
serves the powerful and undermines those
who might rebel against right okay now
let's let's go back to the question of
how opportunity is distributed okay so
for some populations you have very
little opportunity and you have a
tremendous hazard of falling off the
bottom of the ladder and not having
there's not enough mechanism to allow
you to get back to it that creates crime
let's say that those who control or who
write the rules of the system do not
want a revolt even though this scenario
would set them up for it right so one
thing that happens is you create a
tendency to incarcerate right you have
rules that freeze certain people out of
opportunity and then you have a system
that is capable of incarcerated massive
numbers of them and we incarcerate a
much larger fraction of our population
than any comparable nation right and a
very disproportionate fraction of people
in that system are black so here's the
part that I don't hear discussed when
you take men out of a population it has
a very predictable effect you take men
out of a population it undercuts the
bargaining position of women in mating
and dating
right so if you take men out of the
population it means that those men who
are still present in that population are
in very high demand right now men being
men if they're in high sexual demand it
is hard to get them to settle down right
a man who has lots of options is much
harder to persuade to become monogamous
and participate in traditional family
raising okay so what that does is it
creates an environment in which you have
many more single-parent homes many more
children growing up without their
fathers present which of course hobbles
the kids who are raised in that
situation because humans are so
difficult to raise they're so costly in
terms of time and energy and resources
that one person has a much harder time
doing it than a team of two people and
this sets in motion all of the things
for which white society imagines that
there's some cause inside of being black
when in fact it's a demographic process
a demographic process that unfolds very
naturally if you remove a
disproportionate number of men from a
population and undermine women's
bargaining position that making sense
absolutely okay so why are we not having
that discussion and why are we instead
talking about shutting down stem stem is
exactly what you need in order to
understand how that process works and to
figure out what you would have to do to
fix it well I think those things are in
many people's are so distantly connected
you know what they look at the economic
disparity in the crime and the gang
problem and the prison problem and the
incarceration problem and they look at
that and then they look at stem as being
a completely different thing it's like
what your your connection and what the
what you're saying about the the fact
that the hobbling of these communities
is so systemic it's so it's so a part of
how they're established and set up and
there's and it's repeating itself over
and over and over again generation after
generation you know that in many
people's eyes it doesn't doesn't seem
related
it doesn't seem related exactly and this
is this is why you need those
Enlightenment values and the tools that
arise out of them right to be able to
look at it scientifically right if this
is this is causal yeah you have to go
dispassionate in order to make a
compassion they can't see they can't be
taboo subjects that can't be breached by
white people because of your privilege
right so what I am watching is a train
wreck in which we have a movement that
is unhooking exactly the tools necessary
to see what really is going on right
right there really is a problem and what
this movement is doing is it is
advancing a phony explanation bad policy
and then on the other side everybody
who's not going along with this you know
or a vast majority of those who are not
going along are thinking okay those
people are just crazy right they're
complaining about something that doesn't
exist this is this is nonsense it's
chaos and we it has to be shut down and
so anyway that the truth is neither of
those things the the movement is
advancing wrong ideas but the energy
that fuels the movement is about real
legitimate complaints yeah and the
people who are against the movement
because they don't buy what's being said
or don't understand the actual
unfairness in our system are being
emboldened by this they're not being
woken up to it they're being deafened to
the fact that there's actually a problem
that needs solving and they're thinking
the whole thing was phony to begin with
right so that looks to me like kind of
worst possible like we're setting
ourselves up not to be able to solve
this and if we don't solve it we are
headed to chaos one way or another even
if this dies down it'll be back yeah I
feel that always when I hear people
discuss jobs like when I hear
presidential candidates discussed jobs
and unemployment and you know and and
boosting up the economy and like when
Trump discusses the fact that you know
when the economy was doing well before
Co vid that there was black unemployment
was at an all-time low and that you know
he was all these great things were
happening
it's like addressing
you're not dressing the foundation
you're the only addressing like the
windows of a house we keep the windows
shut and this house is solid but if the
foundation is rotten because the
termites and you're just ignoring it and
you just keep stacking boards up to
level it out when one side sinks because
the rotten wood gives way you're not
fixing that you these are temporary
patches the real issue is is very clear
the one of the ways I've looked at it is
in this is a very simplistic way that I
sort of say if you really wanted to help
America be really patriotic what's the
best way to help America well you'd want
less losers how do you get less losers
you find the spots where the people have
an unfair shot and you fix that you fix
those spots whether it's a south side of
Chicago whether it's Baltimore you find
these disenfranchised areas and you fix
them that's the only way you give people
much more opportunity you give people
you you set it up so people have if not
the same advantage of far superior
advantage that then they have now in
terms of their ability to make it
through the navigate the the terrifying
waters of being a young adult and
getting through the system without going
to jail and without making terrible
mistakes and then having some sort of an
economic opportunity that it gives you
hope that you actually strive for
something and you get rewarded for your
effort and you see other people get
rewarded for that effort as well and
that becomes the model that you're using
you use this model of you know the model
that we see in a lot of upper-middle
class communities you see there's a path
Mike made it through look at Mike now he
has a Corvette you know Tom made it
through look at that nice house and you
see that and you just emulate that
whereas in these communities that have
been established that they've had this
problem for decade after decade and
nothing's been done about it and so they
hear all this this talk from politicians
about black unemployment and this and
that but meanwhile the [ __ ] neighbor
was exactly the same
no one's done anything to fix it no
one's done anything to - I mean and I
think it's a tremendous
problem in terms of like what effort
needs to be done to fix it and I'm a
[ __ ] I'm not the guy to fix it I don't
I don't understand how it could be done
I don't know but I don't but I do
understand that there's not work being
put into doing it other than through the
people in the community and community
activists and and some some people that
have you know that are philanthropists
sort of tried to figure out a way to do
their best to put a dent in it it's
never been addressed on a national level
it's not addressed like no one's no
president has ever made an address even
Obama what they've sat down and said
here's the areas of this country where
it's really hard to make it and this is
what we're gonna do to fix that yeah I
agree but I still don't think here at
the root what's the root the root is a
system that is so politically corrupt
that it is not even interested in doing
what it needs to do it is interested in
doing the bare minimum that it can do
that prevents revolt and now it's
screwed up now it's got revolt on its
hands but if you actually wanted to
solve this problem you have to solve it
at the causal level right you can't have
a system in which people are choosing
between candidates from to corrupt
parties both of which are hell-bent on
stealing well-being from them and
transferring it to their actual
constituents I agree
so yeah that's problem as well I don't
think it's a problem as well I mean
imagine for a second right how did we
get here it's 2020 we are facing a
global pandemic which incidentally I do
want to talk to you about okay we are
facing a global pandemic we are facing
rioting in the streets a movement that's
showing signs of a Maoist challenge to
the most fundamental aspects of the West
right and we're gonna have to choose
between Donald Trump and Joe Biden what
right neither one of these people is
capable of or inclined towards the kind
of leadership that you have just
described we would need a grade so that
means that a very at the very least if
we do not divert our course
right if November comes and we are
choosing between those two then that
means we're putting off any solution at
least four years because the president
the president would be essential to
changing our course right and this is
just built into these parties now right
Obama I can't figure out why it's the
case I really like Obama personally he
seems like the right guy to me but his
his administration and at a policy level
is indistinguishable from Bush in some
ways it was worse so what we've got is
parties that decide what we get to
choose from and the game is to prevent
us from having any choice that could
possibly solve the problem so we have to
fix that we have to address that problem
and we have to break their stranglehold
and you know in fairness Trump was a
challenge to that two-party duopoly he's
not really a Republican right right but
he's also not really an alternative it's
like a third crime family right yeah
you've got the Republicans the Democrats
and now they sort of co-opted their
ideology to fit his needs yeah but it's
not a solution right so we have to get
that solution which means we have to get
by the parties Trump proved that was
possible right I think if there's any of
it there was ever a time where an
independent party has a chance now is
the time if someone steps in and has a
real solution and also for in terms of
the distribution of that information
now's the time because you could just
post something on YouTube where you're
demonstrating like through a
step-by-step process you could take
hours to do it like this is what I want
to do and this is how I'm gonna do it
you break those down the clips almost
like a podcast and if someone was a
person of substance that we really
believed in we said that person can
really do this this actually could
happen let's vote independent it could
happen they don't have a monopoly on the
distribution of information anymore and
that's terrifying to them because they
used to be able to count on the shells
on the left and the right to get the
word out for them but they don't have
that anymore you have so many people
that
really don't have an ideological
foundation in either one of them that
are talking and they're reaching
millions of people that's a rare moment
in time and this is in my opinion the
very best time for someone to step in
that's not they're not compliant they're
not they don't have to give it they
don't they don't need that policy
machine behind them or the political
machine behind them well I've got a plan
okay but we would have to find a really
big podcast I think to get enough
momentum see none of those out there you
haven't encountered a big part you know
they don't exist all right you want to
hear the plan sure okay the rock and
jock were willing well you know let's
put that okay let's put that to the side
it's not part of the plan but it
actually could fit okay so here's the
the plan this plan needs a better name
but the working title is the Dark Horse
duo plan and the plan looks like this we
draft two individuals we find two people
one of them is center-left
and one of them is center-right and
these people have to have certain
characteristics a minimum set they have
to be patriotic they have to be
courageous and they have to be highly
capable right but that's it
okay center-left in a center right and
we pair them together and we draft them
with the following plan that they will
govern as a team that is to say every
important decision will be discussed and
they will decide what to do as a team
and only in cases where they cannot
reach agreement or whether something has
to be whenever something has to be
decided on a very short timescale like a
military decision does the person who
inhabits the role of the president
govern alone okay we draft these folks
and then four years down the road they
switch and the one who had run for
president now runs for the vice
presidential spot and the one who was
vice president now runs for president
and they continued this way until one of
two things happens either we vote
someone else in or one of them has
inhabited the office of president twice
and is no longer
and then that person has to be replaced
so we have a patriotic team governing
together from center left and center
right well you say drafted that's the
problem like someone has to be motivated
to ruin their [ __ ] lives to try to
run this country that's what happens to
everybody that does it I agree but then
that's an obstacle you're spelling out
or an obstacle that I would argue is
solvable that we know these people who
okay so okay let's just say that's the
plan so far you can talk about what
problems it solves as much as you want
you're welcome to have it but okay so
here's my proposal so the plan could be
right and my proposal for who we draft
could be wrong and I'm happy to see
other people swapped in okay but my
proposal would be Admiral William
McRaven on the right you know who that
is
no I don't ok he is a Navy SEAL former
Navy SEAL he was until 2018 the
Chancellor of the University of Texas he
is a very cogent center-right Republican
he was the lead on the bin Laden raid
and he is
I think universally respected by people
who know him I've never heard anybody
say negative things about him on the
center-left let me see this gentleman
yeah you're gonna know oh yeah your
president to me yeah it looks like a
president to me too you know who else
looks like a president to me Oh Andrew
yang I'm down with that okay so like
what you're saying now good so here's my
point
those two guys together those two is
that camera on yes Admiral
your country needs you it really does
never more than now and I know that the
job of president is a sucky one I heard
the job of vice presidents even worse
but please consider this plan because
the Republic is in jeopardy
now we already know that Andrew yang is
up for the job because he ran for her
office yeah you know faced appallingly
stupid obstacles that in my opinion may
in be the reason that he's not the
nominee so here we got two people one of
them I think will do so out of duty the
other is crazy enough to want the job in
the first place and what are they well
they're both Patriots
they're both courageous and they're both
highly capable this is the road out I
don't know the Navy SEAL gentleman but
Raven McRaven but Andrew Yang has some
really good ideas yeah I mean and
reasonable ideas across the board and
when in terms of many things not just
universal basic income which was the
thing that he was most popular for but
but even law enforcement he's got some
great ideas about a lot of things he
thinks outside the box a brilliant guy
open to anything yes
I'm sorry reasonable so I would suggest
one last part of the plan right which is
that we Americans have to get over the
idea that when somebody runs for office
especially the office of the president
that the right reaction is to ask them a
million questions about what they will
do in office what policies they advocate
this is absurd presidents don't make
policy they certainly influence what
policy is made but the important thing
about a president is that they listen to
the right sorts of people and that they
have a mind capable of processing what
they hear so that they can integrate the
information necessary and in the case of
this plan we're talking about two people
who would do that as a team so what I
would really be interested in as they
are running against Trump and Biden is
hearing who it is that they would bring
into an administration how would they
make decisions about the things that
matter to us and figuring out who they
would bring in I think is bound to be
far more informative than dogging them
about you know what they're gonna do
about health care and how they're going
to pay for the thing about asking
someone what they're going to do though
is it does influence people whether or
not they're willing to vote for that
person they want to see a plan
I know what you're saying is a
reasonable person who understands the
system but for the average American they
do want to see a plan to how to get out
of a lot of the messes that we see well
you know the funny thing is we think a
lot of things are true about what people
want for one thing we've been told that
people are stupid and that you know
they're hopeless and if you know I mean
you're really one of the earliest
innovators here you have found that
people that we've been told have an
attention span so short that they can
only deal with a sitcom are interested
in a three-hour conversation about
complex topics with people from all over
the map right people are ready to listen
what I'm trying to say is we have a
wrong idea right in our in our sense of
what elections are and really that wrong
idea isn't even about the fact that we
think we want to hear the plan it's
about the fact that we know that our
power in the system is so limited that
the only way we could possibly exert any
influence on the policy that gets made
is if we can get somebody to promise us
something into a camera enough that
they're embarrassed not to do it when
they get an office and we also know that
doesn't work right they just do whatever
they're gonna do in ranch place
so my point would be look I will I will
literally vote for any competent
courageous Patriot I actually don't care
in what direction of their ruling yes I
would prefer that they were progressive
because I believe we need to make
progress or we will perish but any
courageous capable Patriot is good
enough because a courageous capable
Patriot will do way better than we are
doing with the current method yeah and
I'm seeing this one thing the I keep
hearing over and over again from people
on the left that really disturbs me it's
this concession that what you're voting
for is the cabinet you're voting for the
the you know you're the Supreme Court
you're voting for someone who's not
going to reverse Roe vs. Wade that's
what I keep hearing from my friends on
the left and you know they've basically
just they just made this concession in
their head like hey you know this is
what i'm voting for now they've given up
and the news media on the left has
completely ignored all of these Biden
speech
is that clearly show some sort of
cognitive decline in fact I've actually
like David Pakman who I respect a lot he
was kind of arguing against it that it
didn't that it didn't show his decline
and I was I was trying to look at it in
a way that it made sense I was trying to
be rational about him like okay maybe
he's just exhausted or maybe this or
maybe it's pressure you know sometimes
people get really tongue-tied and panic
under pressure and words come out all
[ __ ] up that that is possible but
there's a trend and if you go back to
when he was a younger man that trend
didn't exist it's you're seeing it
you're seeing a change and the idea that
as you get older you become less
comfortable with the media less
comfortable with speaking publicly that
doesn't jive with me right that doesn't
make any sense so like I agree with you
I see a decline but irrespective of what
that is Joe Biden is an influence
peddler yes he is not an idea guy right
he's the same idea as Hillary Clinton in
a different morphology who cares this is
not an answer to any known question this
is stay the course at a moment when we
could not afford to stay the course less
right so look how dare the Democratic
Party do this to us again
at this moment well they did it to us
before this moment happened that's the
thing they did it to us before kovat and
they did to us before the looting and
before the damage it was this moment
these things think they thought it was
gonna happen the way it happened I
thought they when they if I thought that
I feel like they felt that if they got
Joe Biden in there if none of this stuff
had happened you would just be dealing
with one solution to the problem that is
Donald Trump right but even if we are if
we bend over backwards to be generous to
the Democratic Party yes it did this in
a moment when we didn't know that kovat
19 was going to spread right and we
didn't know that there was going to be
massive riots in the streets over who
knows how many cities we did we should
have known that this was building
right the possibility of a pandemic was
always on the table the fact that we
have a pandemic and that that makes it
clear well why we need a cogent leader
it was obvious that this could happen
under any presidency but there's a lot
of other things it's hard to say that
the possibility of a pandemic is on the
table so we should have been prepared
for it
I mean the possibility of an asteroid
will impacts on the table the
possibility of a solar flare that wipes
out the power grid always on the table
yeah but you're making my point my point
is you can never afford to have somebody
who isn't a courageous capable Patriot
in that office how dare they play games
with this thing it's not theirs to screw
up right and this also was highlighted
the problem of Donald Trump's ego yeah
you know I mean people would say these
egos yeah he's got an ego problem but
look he's getting the job done he's
doing great things but then in the face
of this pandemic when he's being
criticized like almost to the point
where he can't handle it anymore
you know like some people can run at a
pace of 5 miles an hour but when you
force him to run at a pace of 7 miles an
hour things get slippery you know you
start you start feeling cramps you start
looking for a way out and he's right now
about 9 miles an hour and it's not
looking good nothing's I mean he's
tweeting about not falling down a ramp
and why were you walking like that he's
all the fake news media doesn't was a
slippery ramp and I'm not gonna give
them a ring like what the [ __ ] are you
even paying attention to yeah the fact
that your ego is so fragile you're
paying attention to criticisms the way
you walk down a slippery ramp like they
would have ignored that it would have
been a non-issue but it's an issue that
you your ego is so fragile that you have
to address the fact that they're
criticizing the way you walk down a ramp
with [ __ ] slippery dress shoes on
those shoes suck I never wear wear those
I went to a cowboy boot store the other
day and I was like what do you do with
these bottoms like I'm thinking if you
got to get away from something some
shit's going down you can't run with
these [ __ ] things on now they're for
dancing so you can yeah you slip around
with that claim but that's what dress
shoes are yeah they wear those leather
soles dress shoes that slip like crazy
there's no tread on them they're not
that's what that guys wearing walking on
a ramp well and you know she boosts a
nice pair of Adidas with some good
traction I agree I always wear practical
shoes because you know when you're on
[ __ ] goes down exactly yeah exactly so
they eat the ego is you know it
highlights which it gets it gets really
magnet or you find the weaknesses in the
system when the system gets tested and
now it's being tested across the board
across the board and that insecurity
believe me our enemies know it's there
oh for sure they know how to exploit it
yeah so enough games yeah we have to
escape this and you know to my friends
who are still believers in the
Democratic Party at some point of which
I have many if you hate Trump right if
that's really your cause and you're not
gonna be able to see clearly anything
until we are we have removed him from
office that is also on the Democratic
bill Hillary Clinton advanced Trump's
candidacy because she wanted to run
against him so if you if you have Trump
derangement syndrome you still have to
be angry at the Democratic Party for
putting us in this predicament yeah she
legitimately thought he'd be the easiest
to beat so she wanted him to run she
thought she was going to humiliate him
she severely underestimated people that
were upset at the current system and
that his rhetoric this idea of draining
the swamp would actually resonate with
so many people and also that people look
at things in a very two-dimensional way
you know they're not looking at it in
this really complex nuanced way and if
you can paint a couple of good slogans
together build that wall make America
great again all that all that kind of
[ __ ] that that is like that's a
brilliant way of manipulating people
because that's the stuff they remember
and he's a master at it
sleepy Joe Brydon crazy Hillary Clinton
lyin Hillary you know he crazy Ted lyin
Ted he has all these nicknames for
people I don't even remember most of
them but there's some brilliance in it
oh he is a he's a political genius yes
yes well a manipulative genius in the
sense that he understands how to use the
media because he's been in it forever
these [ __ ] people have been in
in this bush-league way like you you
don't even know what it's like they have
a real master communicator in that role
have you had someone that was a master
public speaker in that role really knew
how to give a a blistering takedown of
someone like Trump or someone like Biden
he's easy easy both those guys you know
they're vulnerable is [ __ ] they are and
let's get them the hell out of there as
you point out and you are dead right
about this if ever there was a moment
this would be it yeah this would be the
moment but do you think you can get that
guy to run we have to draft him it's a
matter of duty and I is he doing right
now I don't know I think I think he may
have retired after he left the the
transfer position probably right now
digging a bunker somewhere outside of
Waco [ __ ] this place but you know I mean
look the way the way you would draft
somebody like that is you would let them
know that we'd have their back mm-hmm
right yeah we they would earn our
loyalty and they would have to have it
but if they did then it's the perfect
moment do you think there's enough time
here we are in the middle of jute was it
the 16th 15th what is today 16 16th of
June July August September October
November five months actually the world
we could be you know we could be
speaking Chinese in five months look
yeah you ain't kidding look the thing
about 2020 the thing about 2020 is I
don't you can make an argument about
what's possible but 2020 is not the year
to make such an argument in because it
through all the [ __ ] wrenches into the
gears every race and into the oil into
the eyes yeah it's [ __ ] crazy I'm
going stark raving sane mmm yeah me too
yeah I think so you want to talk about
Co vid I do what are your what are your
thoughts on that what do you thoughts on
the lockdown yeah well let's put it this
way I'm I'm not speaking in a vacuum
here I've heard a certain amount of your
take and my take is a bit different I am
very concerned about SARS Cove - I am
NOT concerned about it because it is
as lethal as we feared it might be it
isn't as lethal as we feared it might be
but I'm afraid of yet for other reasons
one it is brand-new to us evolutionarily
it just showed up in human beings and so
in my opinion we screwed up the lockdown
badly because we went half way that a
very short very intense lockdown
could have ended it and that that would
have been the smart thing to do and
unfortunately the political will was not
there but if you're I am looking at New
Zealand with utter envy imagine at this
moment being free of SARS Cove - yeah
they nailed it but they also have so few
people no they definitely had it easier
but the point is they did prove it was
possible yes so in my opinion we should
have locked down severely for six weeks
or something along those lines and we
should have driven it to extinction and
the problem is that that runs afoul of
all kinds of things including civil
liberties concerns which I also hold I
hate the idea of a government crackdown
in which they're dictating with whom you
associate and all of the rest I mean I
hate it as much as anyone but we are
dealing with a brand new landscape when
it comes to a global pandemic and what's
more we are dealing with a virus that I
think is not what we have been told it
is how so so I have initially I thought
that this was a bat borne virus that had
been transmitted to people from the wild
probably through the bushmeat trade
probably through the seafood market in
wuhan in fact Heather and I were in the
Amazon where we had no connectivity to
anything for a couple weeks when we came
out what was then called novel
coronavirus was just beginning to be
discussed and it so we became aware of
it as we came out of the Amazon's like
oh what the heck is not huh
and I looked into it and immediately I
saw the story adds up you know it's a
coronavirus of a kind that's known to
circulate in bats there's a seafood
market and I thought okay I know what
the story isn't I tweeted I don't know
enough about the story yet but looks to
me like the Wu hen on seafood market is
the source that the virus comes from
bats and we have to talk about the
bushmeat trade which has always been a
terrible idea and immediately people
tweeted back at me so you think it's
just a coincidence that there's a
biosafety lab level four in Wuhan where
this started and I thought what that's a
heck of a coincidence
and so I started to look into it I
retracted the tweet I said maybe I don't
know enough about the story yet and I
started to look into it and I went down
the rabbit hole because as much as we
have been assured by a huge range of
experts that this has to have been a bat
borne corona virus transmitted to people
possibly through pangolins maybe through
some intermediate hosts that we don't
yet know that story looks less and less
likely and the story that is looking
more and more likely what I would call
the lab leak hypothesis is looking ever
stronger and anyway I've been in contact
with other people who have reached that
conclusion we have faced all kinds of
pushback but in a sense again we still
don't know it is possible that this came
from the wild without human meddling but
the the virus itself has several
components that suggest that it is
actually the result of manipulation in
the lab and that it escaped probably
from the Han Institute of biology but
there's another lab in Wuhan it it may
well have escaped and we may be dealing
with consequences are the root of the
the fact that it was manipulated in the
lab so one of the techniques that labs
who study viruses like this they use is
something so the research is called
gain-of-function research
means you are taking a virus and you are
adding a capacity to it in order to
study how it works and then one of the
things that is done to study how it
works is something called passages where
a virus is infected and a creature is
infected with the virus and then the
virus is allowed to pass between
individuals of that species it can also
be done in tissues and cellular tissues
where tissues are infected and the virus
is allowed to spread from one cell to
the next and what happens is evolution
so there is a strong possibility that
this virus was under study that it was
enhanced in the laboratory and that we
are dealing with consequences that are
the result of that enhancement that make
it more dangerous than it would
otherwise be and what do you believe
those enhancements are well so the
enhancements of one of the enhancements
there is a something called a foreign
site a fern site in the genome of this
virus fern sites are not known it
doesn't mean they don't exist but
they're not known from other beta corona
viruses and this fern site is
conspicuous its conspicuous in that it
is in the genome is an insert rather
than mutations of nucleotides that were
there it's like somebody spliced it in
that's one thing which could happen
naturally but it may well not have and
it has a flanking sequence which has
this is probably gonna be hard for
people to follow but nucleotides that is
DNA code for proteins which are made out
of amino acids there's an amino acid
called arginine and there are two
arginines coded for in the genome of
this virus but because there are so many
possible codes triplet codes and only 20
or so amino acids there's redundancy and
so which code is used to trigger the
production of an or the the inclusion of
an arginine is variable and the two
arginines
are coded for in a way that is not seen
in in nature in this way very frequently
so
let's just say there are elements of the
genome that are conspicuous and suggest
possible laboratory manipulation the
fern site that I refer to that has been
inserted either by a natural process or
by a laboratory process greatly
increases the transmissibility of this
virus which means various things it
could be the explanation for why this
virus is infecting so many different
tissues in people who get sick right the
list of symptoms is huge here and that's
a very troubling thing from the point of
view of treating it medically is all of
the things that can go wrong with the
body once you're infected it also means
that the virus is very good at jumping
between people and that high
transmissibility is obviously one of the
things that makes kovat 19 such a
difficult pandemic to control right it's
hopping between people so readily that
it just it runs away so in any case and
then there's a third question that I
have which is maybe that there's
something about the fact I don't want to
say fact as if it is a fact but if this
was an escape from the laboratory then
the virus I mean just as you know maybe
we'll end up talking about the telomere
problem in mice which you spoke to Eric
about when he was on your podcast last
but evolution to the lab evolution in
the lab takes place and changes that the
people in charge want to happen occur
and then things they're not even
thinking about occur
there's adaptation to the laboratory
environment the people who work in labs
are on unaware of and so one of the
questions I have is this virus is highly
transmissible unless you're outdoors
then it seems almost not transmissible
that's a very conspicuous I mean for one
thing bats live outdoors right so is it
possible that this virus has adapted to
the laboratory environment an indoor
environment and that it has forgotten
how to get transmitted outdoors and if
we are casual about the outdoor and fire
that actually it could relearn that
trick that we should take it we a we
need to be outdoors for various reasons
one it appears that vitamin D is very
protective in the case of kovat 19
prevents the transmission and you end up
way less sick if you have proper vitamin
D so in the northern hemisphere here
while the sun is shining we should be
outdoors we should not be locking down
those environments at all we should also
be very careful outdoors right because
anytime we allow it to be transmitted
outdoors that is going to that creates a
evolutionary signal a selective signal
that's going to retrain the virus to be
transmitted outdoors which is not
something we want at the moment this
might be an advantage that we have and
we're gonna lose it if we're not careful
which is why I'm very careful and why I
wear this thing around so that you know
I can pull it up at a moment's notice if
I'm going to talk to somebody because
even though I think the virus is very
difficult to transmit outdoors which is
something we've seen in the data of
South Korea for example it could learn
that trick and why is it easier for it
to trend do we know why don't know
indoors we don't know so we don't know
the mechanism and there's no good reason
that we don't know we should know
because it could be that it's UV light
UV light is very powerful destructive
stuff but if it's UV light then that
suggests it's difficult to transmit
outdoors during the day and it should be
easy to transmit outdoors at night if
it's not UV light then that's not likely
to be it so there is something weird
going on with viral load maybe it's not
weird but it's it's weird for those of
us who learned how viruses work from the
the usual textbook diagrams where a
virus gets into a cell and triggers and
infection but here it seems like if you
talk to someone briefly your chances of
picking it up from them even if they're
sick is pretty low but if you talk to
somebody for an extended period of time
or you're constantly breathing air that
they're exhaling then your chances go up
up up and up and that's so there's a
possibility that just exposure to UV
light as people even if they're outside
talking for the same amount of time just
the fact that these particles are going
through the air in the Sun
like that it kills the virus's ability
to transmit it's possible I don't know
that when you think about things like
your you know what a SteriPEN is Oh like
a UV it like it yeah it's a UV wand the
backpackers used so they can drink creek
water yeah it's crazy if you ever seen
one it's not doesn't even take that long
yeah you take this wand you put it in
like a bottle water bottle and you spin
it around in this creeks water and it
kills all the bad stuff totally and it's
weird man it's weird the light can do
that oh my goodness well the UV light is
amazing stuff yes well you know what
happened when Trump said something about
getting UV light into the body well
there was an actual publicly traded
biotech company that had an invention
for when people are intubated taking
this this tube with UV light and
inserting it into the lungs of these
people and they were actually pulled off
of Twitter Twitter actually banned their
account because they thought there was
some wacky Trump supporter who was
trying to substantiate the president the
president just got lucky you know he's
basically claiming to get the light put
it in the body somehow the body
disinfect the cleansing you remind me of
Sarah Cooper when you knew he was he was
on to something though in a weird way
that this publicly traded biotech
company had an idea that when people
they are on an Inc into what they have
been intubated when they are on this
ventilator this tube will go down the
same tube that the air is coming through
yeah and actually flood the lungs where
they're infected with kovat 19 with UV
light and kill it well the thing is I
don't think he got lucky I think he did
something that he's routinely doing
which isn't very high quality in terms
of leadership but somehow he's getting
briefings he's tuned into some channels
there was discussion I remember seeing
it there was discussion about how UV
light might be used to treat the cove at
19 infection and I was actually alerted
by this discussion to the fact that
there was apparently a lot of work on
this technique previously that actually
UV light had been successfully used in
various ways where it could be used to
purify blood and things and I was
surprised to discover it and then I
heard the president say this and I
thought that that's what he was talking
about my guess is something crossed his
feed somebody in a briefing said well
mr. president there is a promising
theory of promising therapy bla bla bla
bla bla uv-light bla bla bla bla bla and
he just walks out the door and riffs on
which is why Sarah Cooper is so funny
because basically she exposes the I
don't know who Sarah Cooper oh you know
maybe I do you've probably seen her
she's um making these videos where she
lip-synchs Trump oh that's no she's not
the one who did the thing where was it a
doctor faking Stein or the fake inning
put Trump's face on a baby have you ever
seen that one no I haven't seen that
well that one's wonderful the best ones
ever you haven't run into circular I may
have I've seen so many people mark him
it's so hard to keep track of who's who
okay but there she is yep let's give me
some volume on that more for the black
community than any other president and
let's take a pass on Abraham like him
because he did good although it's always
questionable you know in other words the
entries that we are free mr. president
but we Honest Abe is because you say you
in general that is the dumbest [ __ ]
thing a person's ever said has been in
office well that may he's done more than
maybe Abe Lincoln who freed the slaves
he's giving a blink in a pass because he
did pretty good
how crazy is a it's crazy right just
like he's stuck he said something and
then he gets stuck trying to
substantiate what he said he should have
said except for obviously a Valenta to
sleep freed the slaves and everyone
would have been like yeah okay it's
braggadocious but perhaps reasonable
it's wrong and stupid but at least it's
not crazy so I absolutely [ __ ] and
saying yeah and then the fact that he's
saying it to a black woman's like oh my
god yeah well he so that's the thing is
he's winging it swinging that's what
she's doing she's just lip-syncing well
unfortunately I don't know whether the
audience saw it in sync or not find a
baby one the baby ones amazing if you
don't have it I could I could airdrop it
to you the baby one you need to say okay
I guess it's [ __ ] amazing current
somebody it
either the faking or dr. fakin Stein do
you know who was Jamie do you remember
one of those fake artists who takes you
know they use the Face Swap technology
and they put Trump's face on this baby
and then they changed the words that
someone caught a baby doing something
and they talked to the baby and the baby
was trying to live and get their way out
of it it's like an old video but then
they put Trump's face on it and then
they changed here go ahead this is the
original baby Rachel's first yeah yes
you did
you touched its food it's adorable
so now President you said the virus was
just like the flu you did you also said
the virus could go away by April you
said it would disappear like a miracle
you have to see it if you find it folks
anybody's listening to this you should
see it because it's really disturbing
seeing a baby with Trump's face it
almost looks like Sam Kinison as a baby
anyway anyway which brings us back to
McRaven and yang in the dark but still
their covert stuff yeah we have a really
kidding um yeah so what I would say is
first of all I do think I am very much
in favor still of driving this thing to
extinction by being properly sober about
it briefly tonight pause and address
this one issue that seems to be sure
when it seems to be an issue when
someone says that it might have come out
of a lab this is a right wing left wing
thing for whatever reason you get
labeled a right wing conspiracy theorist
if you think it came out of a lab and
you people on the left are so they're so
willing to dismiss that without any real
evidence for we've been poisoned by
these these ideologies when it comes to
conspiracy or whether or not something
is actually
but we've been fed the wrong information
that that stuff is if you don't believe
the official narrative that's being
discussed on CNN you must be some sort
of a right-wing nut right and have you
faced that oh of course I faced it I've
been I'm it's hard to escape it right so
I've tried to be very careful I have
described it as a hypothesis which is
what it is I have tried to show that
there are different probabilities for
the different origin hypothesis even
China now it admits that it wasn't from
the seafood market do that oh yeah what
do they say it's from well don't they
say it's from us I have not heard that I
have but they let's put it this way
there are one of the things that is in
my opinion the strongest piece of
evidence that there that the lab leak
hypothesis may be correct is that there
is a missing phase in the evolution of
this virus when a virus jumps from one
species to another it is not well
positioned it is typically very poor at
its job because it doesn't have any
evolutionary experience with that host
so it's not good at leaping between that
host cells which means that it's always
in very small numbers and it's not good
at leaping from one individual to the
next that's the key question when
something leaps into a new species and
then it becomes a pandemic it's because
it has solved that second problem it has
figured out how to infect that creature
in such a way that the creature spreads
it to others of its kind there is no
evidence in the case of this virus that
that happened it showed up in Wuhan and
spread immediately it became pandemic it
already had experience now how it got
that experience we don't know there are
evolutionary waves this could have
happened right it could be that we have
not found the initial population that
it's circulated in right or it could be
that it circulated in a creature that we
haven't found either but the fact that
there is no evidence that it shows up in
Wuhan and immediately spreads tells us
that this virus was well adapted to our
cells and well adapted to transmit
between individuals and that is
conspicuous one way you could get there
is if somebody a had added components to
a virus in order to make it
transmissible to humans so the research
in question would be research that was
interested in discovering what a
pandemic in humans of a bat borne
coronavirus would be like so that we
could do something about it
maybe we could prevent it maybe we could
create a vaccine ahead of time but if
you're creating a virus that has
enhanced capacity to infect humans in
order to study what will happen if a
virus ever escapes into the human
population then you are running the risk
that the virus you are studying will
escape would they have added something
like a fern site absolutely it is
established in the literature that the
addition of a fern site makes the virus
much more transmissible in human tissue
so if you were going to study it this
would be high in your list of things to
do
you could also passage it through human
tissue in order to effectively train it
on the infectious pathway inside of
people which again we might be suffering
the downstream consequences of that if
it escaped the Wuhan Institute of
biology so these things have an amazing
impact and I hear a lot that what does
it matter it's with us now we just have
to deal with it which is nonsense
because a we need to have it never
happen again
be there may be things that we could
understand about what its nature is that
would help us fight it but see we have a
really serious problem now because all
but a few of the world's leading
virologists the experts in coronaviruses
in particular have sworn that this must
have come from nature and couldn't have
come from the lab which is nonsense why
do you think they did that
unfortunately this goes back to our
earlier discussion our scientific system
is broken we need our scientists to be
empowered to tell us what we need to
know and we need them there
for to be freed from a system where they
are fighting for grant money in order to
continue their work this entire group of
people is now in jeopardy because if
this turns out to have been a leak from
the lab then we are all suddenly going
to become aware that gain-of-function
research puts humanity in jeopardy that
one accident in gain-of-function
research can cause the evaporation of
who knows how many trillion dollars it
could cause and this is one of the other
things I wanted to say to you about the
danger of letting this virus run its
course
if we don't stamp it out we a don't know
that people who have been infected are
not going to continue to have outbreaks
we don't know that yet we don't know
whether or not people who've had it are
going to be immune to it in the future
that's probable but it's not certain and
we don't know that it's not going to
become a permanent fellow-traveller of
humanity the way flu is and even if this
thing evolved to become flu-like if it
became as unserious as the flu the flu
is very serious and the cost that
humanity pays for having flu circulate
every year is immense so even if the
only thing that has happened in the long
term if we let it go and it evolved into
another flu-like pathogen then we have
increased the number of flu-like
pathogens that we have to deal with
annually substantially and that would be
a major loss to humans so my sense that
we should be much more aggressive about
dealing with this is really about the
fact that I think we have a short time
horizon in which to deal with it that it
will learn new tricks and it will become
harder to defeat the longer that we play
around with it and so an aggressive
short-term move it's really you know
it's the lesson of pulling off the
band-aid we're not doing ourselves any
favors by pulling it off slowly so what
do you think we should do right now well
I would say I mean the problem is this a
much harder argument to make
now than it was at the beginning because
we're all so frickin sick of lockdown
I mean Portland is still under full
lockdown but not when it comes to
protests well of course not that's the
other problem right there's a massive
hypocrisy in the way we're treating
businesses versus treating protests oh
it's an epidemic of hypocrisy not only
that de Blasio in New York City won't
allow people when they're asking people
that have tested positive for kovat 19
you're not allowed to ask them whether
or not they've been in a protest so
they're doing contact tracing without
valuable data because they they want to
be progressive that's insane
oh he's insane yes so you asked me what
I would do I would and again I don't
want to be in this position you know
months in here I want to be in this
position months ago of saying the right
thing to do is a six-week lockdown that
will be unbearably painful but hopefully
it'll be short and then intense contact
tracing but we've done the lockdown with
essential businesses open well we've
done that's all real lock they've done a
half-assed lockdown and the thing that
we've done that I find the most
troubling is that we have not
bootstrapped
a mechanism for high-quality ubiquitous
testing because if you want to do if you
did a six-week lockdown a real lockdown
right hold your breath and get through
it and then you open back up with
testing that's so high quality and so
universal that you can spot anything
that happens and you can treat it
locally right you don't come into work
if you don't pass this test and if your
work puts you in contact with other
people were going to test you regularly
right if you did that we could have
driven it to very low levels and then we
could have dealt with the flare-ups but
what we're doing now is we're just
gambling and it's insane right we're
gambling and there is no that I can
detect there is no movement that says
open back up and be very aggressive
about things like masks my feeling is if
you
pushing open back up you ought to be
pushing things that would make opening
back up as safe as possible but our
masks really effective because one of
the things that the CDC was saying was
that you should really only wear a mask
if you're treating a person with kovat
yes except that we can effectively know
that what they were really I don't even
want to give him credit for really
saying it the the motivation for saying
that nonsense was that they were trying
to preserve masks for people who needed
it most
that's what foul she said so they
basically lied to it they lied to us
flat-out which some some of us were not
some of us were shouting and saying this
is garbage advice yeah and you know your
question is do masks really work masks
work when both parties wear them they
work really well so you know and I don't
know why we are pushing this madness of
masks that scream medical right so one
of the things you know bank robber yeah
man you know what's cool bank robber
I'm the Mojito Bendita yeah you've got a
bandana I do yeah but you know the fact
is the bandana all right maybe I look
like a goofball but the fact is it's
more fashionable in my opinion than a
medical professional it's cute it's also
it's also more comfortable though yes so
the fact is I have it I can pull it up
as needed put it down it's not hanging
on my ear and that flexibility the fact
that I don't feel so terrible walking
around with it actually makes me use it
when I should use it the best is really
a neck gaiter have you ever using that
Gator mm-hmm
yeah you wear them when you're hunting
your you want to obscure a lot of your
face you know so animals can't see it
it's all camouflage it breaks up the
pattern or your face
they really just slip it back down again
and pull it back up but it actually
stays in place that makes total sense
but I do I mean the funny thing is I'm
an animal biologist so the same thing
should apply to me but I've never heard
that never heard of a net Gator no I'm
heard of a net Gator for other things
but not for hunting oh yeah oh super
common yeah you pull up there's a photo
of me in lanai wearing a full Sitka
outfit I look like a ninja lanai is a
very interesting place to hunt because
one of the few places where you could
say it's mandatory to hunt animals
because they have an invasive species
called access deer that's me
see that that thing on my face that's a
net Gator and it's actually in the Sitka
the hunting gear that I'm wearing it's
actually built into the hood so in in
it's not just something that you wear
around your neck it actually is built
into it so it slides up and it goes down
on your neck if you'd like it to but
then when you're moving forward it could
slide down these animals that live there
there's literally 30,000 deer on an
island of 3,000 people and there it's an
invasive species they were brought there
and given to king kamehameha by the but
by India in like the 1800s and there's
no predator so they're just out of
control you've never seen anything like
it is crazy when you're there like the
mass populations and it happens to be
one of the most insanely delicious
animals as well also super switched on
because they evolved to avoid Tigers so
I've got videos of these things where in
arrows coming at them from eighty yards
and as the arrow is about you know 15
yards away they hear it and they're get
out of the way they move so fast like
they're the fastest deer I've ever
encountered in my life by far like
nothing's even close to them and you
know you you have to be sneaky to get
close to these things yeah that's why
you dress like that that's cool in some
sense so actually can I connect that the
the viral questions or okay so the
connections going to be a weird one
there is only one terrestrial mammal
natively in Hawaii there's only one
terrestrial mammal species
okay there's aquatic there's whales and
things but and seals but there's uh
there's only one terrestrial mammal
trying to guess what that Bay yeah a
mammal terrestrial mammal
well terrestrial may be misleading here
I just mean on land Oh
seal nope no well they're seals but
that's it's an aquatic mammal okay it's
a bat oh right so here's the thing
Hawaii is as remote from mainland as
anywhere there is really isolated
you know and that means that the story
of how a terrestrial mammal gets there
is pretty rare because think about the
condition how would almost any
terrestrial mammal you can think of get
there so at some point some pregnant bat
probably got blown off-course by a storm
and probably barely crawled up on the
beach you know you know so they flew
thousands of miles well my guess is it
almost never happens
but it did happen once with this bat but
anyway my point would be Hawaii is a
tropical landmass you would think it
would have high diversity because it's
tropical right
tropical places tend to have very high
diversity Hawaii has very low diversity
because it's so far from everywhere
all right so the thing is almost nothing
can make it over the gap that big
saltwater gap is very hard for anything
to cross so what that means is that
everything that's in Hawaii is very well
adapted for things like crossing huge
gaps and not very well adapted for
everything that would compete with that
capacity so that sets Hawaii up for
being invaded by any creature that you
transport there if you can solve the how
do you jump the gap question by
transporting on an airplane or a ship
then the species that are there are not
in a position to fend it off
competitively because they're not
adapted to compete it's a low diversity
environment where everything had to
cross some amazing gap to get there so
it's a sitting duck for invasive species
like the one you're describing okay now
here's the connection to the viruses if
it is true that this virus originally
came from a bat was being studied in
probably the Wuhan Institute of Virology
was enhanced and then escaped was
enhanced for the infection of human
tissue and then escaped it is the
equivalent of us having transported
something very dangerous over a gap it
couldn't have crossed on its own
right and we are sitting ducks for this
thing mmm
so this is why I'm really on high alert
about this now what are your feelings
when it comes to the high number of
people that are asymptomatic or the high
number of people that get it and it's
very small deal to them they just call
for a couple days and then it's no big
deal
yes well so I've been advocating from
the start that we should be much more
aggressive in the way we are studying
this that in fact you remember the
aircraft carrier USS Theodore Roosevelt
had an outbreak and it docked in Guam
mm-hmm
my thought was I want to see that
carrier used to study the virus it's too
bad that it docked in Guam because they
ruined a circumstance and it's not that
I wanted to see people infected and it's
not that I didn't I wanted to see them
get the highest quality treatment
possible but it was an isolated
population in which you could have
studied the spread of this virus and
because it's an aircraft carrier you
could also get anything you needed you
could have built hospitals on the deck
you could have given them the finest
possible care and we could have learned
a lot about how the thing is transmitted
what the symptoms mean who is actually
shedding live virus based on what
symptoms they have rather than studying
this haphazardly amongst infected people
in hospitals where you don't really know
who they've been in contact with and all
of that so we missed that opportunity we
could do the same thing with military
bases or any isolated population where
you can actually have enough data to
know what these things mean as it is
we're left with all kinds of questions
right it seems that some of the people
who are asymptomatic actually have
significant damage to their lungs they
have this ground-glass opacity pattern
in their lungs even though they didn't
show any symptoms and what are the
numbers of these people
well it's been at least a month since
I've seen anything on it but it was a
fairly high percentage it was like 30 or
40 percent I think so
all I can say is that makes no sense to
me right you're talking about
significant damage to the lungs it seems
like that would in and of itself cause a
symptom yeah
I think the people to study would be
those NBA athletes because a large
number of the NBA players attested
positive from at least Jamie you would
know better than me and was at one
particular team where these athletes
were for two or four guys on that team
two or four guys on the team out of 15
16 and they were always symptomatic I
don't think anybody got really sick that
I've heard of it yeah I would like them
to be studied because their peak
physical specimens you know the
professional athletes and it's such a
cardiovascular sport you know you're
constantly sprinting and moving and you
have to be in tremendous shape to play
professional basketball the highest
level I would think I would want to know
what's going on with their lungs yeah
what is it like when you get an elite
athlete and you give them this disease
and why are they in asymptomatic is it a
function of their cardiovascular
endurance I mean is there something
about the capacity of their lungs the
fact that they're I mean what happens
you give that to David Goggin
for instance someone who can run 100
mile races and and and do them
back-to-back you know someone who's
extreme cardiovascular fit it's like
Cameron Haynes or something like that
sure and we want to see that we could
learn a lot about what this thing is
really up to as it is we're we're
grasping at straws yeah got a large list
of symptoms we've got people who seem to
be a somatic and yet asymptomatic and
yet damaged so it's hard to know what to
make of it it's also hard to know what
to make of the haphazard nosov response
to it you know like why are we screwing
this up so badly so you don't you think
that it's we didn't know what it was
when it happened and then when it did
happen there was a lot of competing
information and there was China was
giving us bad information for for one
case the World Health Organization in
January was saying that there's no
evidence that it transmits from person
to person we know that we know now that
that's not the case well but think about
how [ __ ] up our situation is right
imagine that you you had some courageous
highly capable Patriots governing right
this thing gets detected
you call the right people into the room
okay you say okay what would a
reasonable person do at this moment but
then we've got a problem right now you
see another part of our system that has
become feeble and inept you see the
virologists might circle the wagons in
order to protect their access to grant
money so the very people who need to
tell you holy [ __ ] this could be very
dangerous
here's what may have happened and here's
what we would do to figure out what the
epidemiology will look like what the
symptomatology will look like those
people may be covering their asses at
all of our expense so what I'm really
telling you is that yes we have to deal
with kovat 19 but we also have to
bootstrap our way out of a predicament
where our whole system has been overrun
by perverse market incentives that is
causing everybody to turn into a liar or
a dupe I mean we can't live that way
this is that we've got too many high
tech problems to be dealing with
anything other than high quality
information about the nature of those
problems and what the possible solutions
look like but how do we mitigate all
these errors and all the how do you how
do you eliminate all the [ __ ] that
we're dealing with and how do we filter
it out and what what would be like the
best pure information where would it be
distributed from well the you know this
this is weird because it's going to
sound self aggrandizing maybe but what's
happened is you've had the people who
have the right characteristics for this
moment pushed out of the system they've
been told to comply with various things
they've been forced to play games that
corrupt them and those who couldn't do
it the ones who will speak the truth
even when it hurts them get pushed out
in one way or another and so in some
sense this is the moment at which we
have to figure out where those people
went and we have to build a system that
pays attention to what they've seen what
drove them crazy okay and so you know
the telomere story is that story writ
large
let's tell that story because we discuss
it on a podcast with your brother but a
lot of people might not have heard it so
let's let's let's talk about what you
discovered and what what you mean by
this okay so I was a graduate student in
evolutionary biology my specialty was
actually bats well that's what I said I
studied tent making bats which was great
and by the way I think the danger of
virus is leaping from bats to people is
actually less than we are being told the
people who are selling the idea that we
have to study these viruses with
gain-of-function research are leading us
to believe them virus is going to leap
out of a cave at any moment and infect
us and the large number of people who
study bats regularly and are not
catching these diseases suggests that
that's not really true were they the
ones that were skeptical about this idea
that it came out of this wet market no I
actually haven't heard from them but
what I can say is there are thousands of
people who study bats who handle them
regularly and they're not constantly
getting sick so I think what we're
learning is that there are a lot of
viruses that could potentially jump and
could potentially adapt to humans when
they do jump they almost never spread
can I ask you a question before you
continue char's because if I was going
to deviate a soft topic was there there
was a story that I read a long time ago
and I think I read it in the New York
Times and it was a story about these
people that were studying bats and they
had parked themselves out in front of
this gigantic cave to sort of film these
bats coming out of the cave and they
didn't anticipate that the bats were
gonna [ __ ] on them and they got insanely
sick from some hemorrhagic virus and
wound up dying like shortly afterwards
you know of his story I don't know the
story I'm now feeling bad about having
laughed that they got crapped on by
these bad no I should have I should have
warned you that it was a bad story
but I remember reading this story that
you know they talked about the millions
and millions of bats that flew at us
can't believe it was in Africa they flew
out of this cave and that they [ __ ]
whenever they fly out and that these
people didn't think about this they just
wanted to film this thing and they just
got covered in bat [ __ ] and it got in
their eyes it got everywhere and they
got a horrible virus from it it was
definitely a virus no I mean
so there's remember them getting really
sick and dying shortly afterwards and
them not being able to identify exactly
what it was that killed them so let me
let me say a couple things on this front
one there is a pathogen that people who
study bats in caves my bats didn't roost
in caves but people who study bats in
caves sometimes get histoplasmosis which
is a fungus it's a fungus that's also
flix people in the poultry industry um
so anyway that's a danger there are
viruses but the story that you're
describing suggests the pattern that I'm
suggesting which is that sometimes
things jump they don't tend to spread
that jump and spread are two different
skills and the chances that something
jumps are relatively small when
something jumps it then has to spread it
has to accomplish both tricks in order
to become a pandemic and the likelihood
of it doing both things well is pretty
low so most of the time it doesn't jump
and when it does jump it doesn't tend to
spread and it sounds like your example
of these people tragic as it is
represents a case in which something
jumped but didn't spread mmm now there
is also the the lab leak stuff is
extensive but there is one of the pieces
of evidence in that story is that there
were some miners in Yunnan who came down
with an ammonia there was something like
six miners who came down with pneumonia
who had worked in a cave that had these
horseshoe bats so to the extent that the
lab in Wuhan was known to be working on
bat coronaviruses for the purpose of
preventing a pandemic they were getting
their bat coronaviruses from this cave
in Yunnan Province long way from Wuhan
and the cave was identified because
these miners had come down with this
pneumonia of which I think three of them
died so it's again a case in which
something jumped but it didn't spread no
pandemic arose out of it so what we're
looking at is the strong possibility
that we were looking to prevent a
pandemic at some place where something
had jumped but had not spread and then
we took viruses from there and imbued
them with the characteristics that
allowed them to
bread so only its second problem so
that's a frightening story to me it is
frightening and is it particularly
frightening that it's coming out of
China because we're not getting really
good information from them because their
propaganda is so strong yes and no
Chinese have not behaved well they have
not informed us in the way we need to be
informed on the other hand one of the
reasons that this is a political
football rather than a scientific
question is that there is a perception
and in fact this perception has been
amplified by the president that this is
potentially if this leaked from the lab
that this is a Chinese problem yes this
lab in China was part of an
international community of Virology
researchers the grant that they would
have been working from came from the NIH
or at least one of them did so this is
really if this is a lab leak still not
saying it is but that's a strong
possibility if this was a lab leak the
failure is one of the international
scientific community in this particular
lab weren't they didn't they get
admonished for something that happened
within like the last two years they had
gotten safety violations yes and there
was a 2015 paper concerned about
gain-of-function research and the
potential for exactly this sort of thing
to happen so anyway there was concern
but like so many things I think it
hovers outside of most of our awareness
so we discover you know after the
Deepwater Horizon accident we discovered
that we're drilling these really deep
deposits that we can't plug a leak when
it happens after the financial crisis we
discover that we're using leverage in a
way that can cause one of these
catastrophic economic meltdowns the
Aliso Canyon disaster reveals that we're
storing you know natural gas in these
old oil deposits and that it can leak
and not be plugged Fukushima reveals to
us what we've been doing with nuclear
reactors and spent fuel we always find
out after the accident that we're
engaged in some really dangerous thing
now people inside these industries know
but they also have a conflict of
interest so nobody warned
right and we need to really get ahead of
that problem we need to start finding
out what it is that we don't realize
humanity is doing that's gonna go bad on
us next right okay back to the mice okay
so I was a graduate student studying
bats in I was in Michigan and I was
interested in evolutionary trade-offs
that's my signature thing and there was
a very good piece of work from a guy new
George Williams great evolutionary
biologist about the evolution of
senescence that is to say the process by
which we grow feeble and inefficient
with age but most people call aging and
basically this classic paper explained
why it is that creatures like us get old
and die and the answer was basically
this that you have a genome that's
complex
it's full of genes but there aren't
enough genes to have a gene for every
trait that you have in fact they're a
tiny fraction of the number of genes you
would need to cover all of the various
characteristics you have so genes always
do multiple things and in the case when
a gene does something that's very good
for you when you're young at some cost
when you're old selection tends to favor
it because you may not live long enough
to suffer the cost and so if you have
the trait that makes you powerful when
you're young and you've got some cost
that you're gonna pay when you're old
but you're not gonna live to get it it
may be a freebie right so selection sees
early life much more clearly than it
sees late life and it prefers things
that help you early even at a cost of
harming you late that's the basic answer
it's called the antagonistic pleiotropy
theory of senescence but at the point
that I started working we knew that this
was right we could tell that the
hypothesis was true because it matched
all sorts of observations about wild
creatures certain creatures live longer
than others even when you correct for
things like body size so creatures that
fly live longer than creatures that are
of the same type and size that don't fly
why because they can fly away
from danger if you can fly away from
danger you're more likely to make it to
an older age the better selection can
see the harms that afflict you when you
get there so selection doesn't prefer a
bias in favor of youth if you can fly
away from danger same thing applies if
you're poisonous if you have a shell if
you have a really good defense then
selection sees your late life better
okay so we knew that this hypothesis was
right but what we had never found at the
point that I was working in the very
late 90s on this was a gene that matched
the description we knew that selection
was finding these genes and accumulating
them but we had never found one of the
genes in question and that was very
conspicuous I called that the missing
playa trophy so anyway I was sort of on
alert about this it was a curious fact
and I saw a talk given by somebody who
was talking about telomeres
and he was talking about telomeres in
their relationship to cancer so
telomeres are repetitive sequences of
DNA at the ends of our chromosomes and
they grow shorter every time a cell
divides all right so it's like a fuse or
a counter that ticks down each cell
division and it drops to zero and in or
not zero but it drops to a number that
the cell refuses to divide after that
and some people were working in one set
of labs on the possibility that this was
causing us to grow feeble with age
because if your cells can't divide
anymore
then they won't replace themselves and
your tissues won't be able to maintain
right another group was studying this
question of telomeres with relation to
cancer and they were saying Eureka every
time we look in a cancer it has this
enzyme called telomerase turned on which
elongates telomeres and these two groups
were not talking to each other they were
each claiming that they were about to
cure their respective disease one group
was saying if we can activate telomerase
then we can lengthen your life and the
other group was saying if we can turn
off to lamb race we can cure cancer all
right I put two and two together and I
said this is the missing playa trophy
here we have something that is
protecting us that's helping us in youth
we have a counter that is limiting the
number of times a cell can divide and
presumably preventing cancer right and
the cost is you can't maintain your
tissues forever so you grow feeble and
inefficient so that made a hell of a lot
of sense to me I couldn't convince
anybody else that this was sensible I
couldn't even get them to understand
what I was saying because in
evolutionary biology there has
traditionally been a bias not in against
mechanism the study of cellular biology
not because there's anything wrong with
studying cellular biology as an
evolutionary phenomenon but because
early in the study of evolution we just
didn't have the tools to look into the
cells so evolutionary biologists got
used to thinking about the form of
creatures and the behavior of creatures
but not thinking about the internal
mechanisms because it just wasn't a lot
that could be said anyway
I retained an interest in the cellular
biology I saw these two things that
needed to be connected and I started to
work on the puzzle it turned out that
that hypothesis would answer a great
many questions that were otherwise very
difficult to answer with respect to how
aging functions but there was one huge
obstacle the obstacle was that a fact
that was well known about mice did not
fit with the idea that telomeres were
fundamental to the aging process and the
fact that was known was that mice had
extremely long telomeres and yet they
lived short lives so if it were true
that the length of your telomeres
dictated how quickly you were going to
age then a tiny creature with very long
telomeres ought to be able to replace
his tissues really well and it should it
should it should age very very slowly so
I thought there's got to be something
wrong with this the hypothesis answers
to many questions for that obstacle to
be real and I thought maybe it's maybe
one person has run a test and everybody
else is just parroting it and I went and
I looked and that wasn't the case and I
finally realized that all of the mice
that we had been looked at were coming
from one source that there was a
laboratory in Bar Harbor Maine called
the Jax lab that was the source for all
of the mice being used in all of the
laboratories in the country and I
started to wonder is there something
going on it that maybe Mouse telomeres
aren't long the ultra long telomeres of
mice aren't real maybe that's a feature
of laboratory mice and wild mice would
have short telomeres in which case the
hypothesis would make sense and I called
up one of the leading people in the
field woman named Carol Greider who's
now won a Nobel Prize and I said Carol
you don't know me I'm an evolutionary
biology graduate student I have a
question for you is it possible that all
mice don't have long telomeres that
that's really just laboratory mice and
she said well I think mice have long
telomeres
but it's interesting if you order must
spread us rather than mus musculus and
you order them from Europe then how long
their telomeres are depends on what
supplier you get them from so this is
interesting so anyway we both agreed
that it was really interesting she
decided she was gonna test the
hypothesis she put her graduate student
Mike Heymann on the case we exchanged
some emails and anyway they tested it
and they got some mice that weren't
really wild but they were much more
recently in captivity and lo and behold
they had short telomeres okay so that
was an amazing moment
my prediction had turned out to be true
which meant a that my hypothesis about
senescence and cancer and aging might
well be true
that was important but it also raised a
bunch of really difficult problems one
was if it is true that all the mice that
are being used to study physiology are
broken in this way then how are we
blinding ourselves is it possible that
we are using all of these mice that
would be terrible models for wound
healing for senescence for cancer for a
whole number of things
how is it that we are allowing ourselves
to take these mice who have been altered
and using them as models for normal
physiology
the other problem may be even more
serious was that we use these animals in
drug safety testing and the way we use
them is if you think about if you'd come
up with a drug that you thought was
useful and you wanted to test whether it
was safe to administer it to people you
can't really afford to give people a
drug and then wait 4050 years to figure
out whether you've shortened their lives
right so at the point that you start
testing these things on humans you're
really in the final stage the way we
test whether a drug is safe for
long-term use or whether it is safe for
your long term life based on short use
is we give large doses of it to small
animals that live short lives on the
assumption that if it's going to shorten
your 80 or 90 year life by 10 or 20
years that a little shorten the mouse's
life long enough to see it but here's
the problem if you've altered a mouse in
the laboratory environment by favoring
the radical elongation of its telomeres
then it has the ability to replace its
tissues in definitely a toxin that will
harm you by killing TIFF you may not
harm that Mouse in fact it may actually
help it because these mice are very
cancer prone so when we give a toxin
that will damage you to a mouse that is
highly resistant to tissue damage you
may slow down its tumors and in fact
we've seen this a number of times where
a drug is given to mice and we get back
the paradoxical result not only is it
not toxic it actually makes the mice
live a little longer all right
so my contention is that we had a
problem where we were testing drugs to
see if they were safe
on animals that were predisposed to tell
us that they were and then when those
drugs were released into the human
population it turned out they were not
safe and people docked
and the problem is I was absolutely
unable to alert the world to this
problem for reasons that still elude me
I published my paper I went through I
don't think we need to bore your
audience especially if they've been
through Eric's description with the
details of what happened in the attempt
to bring this to public attention but
the world of scientists working on the
question was unwilling to respond to the
discovery that their model organism had
this fatal flaw that was going to
predispose us to see certain things and
not other things in the laboratory
environment the governmental Commission
that was charged with studying the Vioxx
scandal which I believe was likely the
result of something like this in its
300-page report doesn't mention mice it
doesn't the Vioxx scandal which was it
was a drug for arthritis correct yeah
gay people strokes yeah it did heart
damage yeah and so anyway heart damage
is actually probably not heart damage
and by that what I mean is if you take a
drug a substance that damages tissues in
the human body it will show up as heart
damage because of the special nature of
the heart so let's say that you took
some drug that you know killed every
10,000 cell or every thousand cell that
would be destructive all over your body
the heart though is a special tissue the
heart has a very low capacity for self
repair at a cellular level very low for
reasons we could go into if you wanted
but because it has a low capacity for
self repair it is also very vulnerable
to something that does some kind of
general tissue damage and it's also an
organ that when it fails it's absolutely
conspicuous so you would expect that if
we had substances that were body-wide
toxins and we released them into the
public having tested them on mice and
not discovering that they were dangerous
that you would see relatively young
people die from heart conditions which
is where we would detect that there's a
problem before we would detect it
anywhere else
hmm so anyway the the government studied
this problem after after Vioxx and it
put together a report and the reports
300 pages it doesn't mention mice it
doesn't mention the genus Massa do you
think they did that to protect
themselves well what I know is that I
attempted to call their attention after
the report came out I looked at it and
you know it had a physical form but it
also had it lives online you can search
it and I could see that telomeres
weren't mentioned mice weren't mentioned
rodents aren't mentioned and so I tried
to alert them to the fact that they had
screwed up and I they blew me off they
wouldn't talk to me so that is it raises
a question and I to this day cannot
answer the question I can't even say
whether or not so when I've tried to
raise this issue I have run into various
kinds of resistance if I raise it with
journalists what I get back is typically
I get interest back at first and they
say ok I'm very interested in the story
I'm gonna pursue it I'm gonna make a few
phone calls and then they come back to
me and they either they go silent or
they say well I talked to some people
and they said it's been taken care of
right well I don't know what it's been
taken care of means I published a paper
that said here's a hypothesis about
what's going on here's my I proposed a
mechanism whereby telomere elongation
would have happened in the breeding
colonies in question and it's been taken
care of it's a very strange way to
describe something that could be an
enormous problem well not only let's say
that it was taken care of right let's
say that they have altered the the
breeding protocol and they fixed the
problem you still have all those drug
tests that they've done for you got all
those drug tests you've got all of the
papers you've got my paper which
proposes a hypothesis and I have a right
to say actually it turns out to be
correct or it wasn't right but so anyway
we got back all of these weird answers
it's been taken care of or even more
curious is the argument well everybody
knows that the mice are bad models which
is insane because this
tell him you actually got that response
yeah from several people I went to
several different journalists and it
wasn't that I was told who they
contacted what I was told was that they
contacted somebody and this is what they
heard and so they their enthusiasm
evaporated at the point they make a
phone call
so did were they not aware of the
consequences of this problem with these
mice so again this is we have a serious
problem
it's not about mice it's not about
virology right it's a general systemic
failure of a reason so what I
encountered as a young somewhat naive
graduate student was an instance which
frankly woke me up to the fact that my
colleagues even when human life was it
on the line we're going to pretend they
didn't know what was going on it's quite
possible they didn't know until I had
put out my hypothesis and Carol Greider
who later pretended she didn't know what
I was talking about published the
empirical work that revealed that indeed
labra lab mice are unusual in having
long telomeres after that work was out
there's no excuse for not investigating
what the consequences were I cannot
explain it except to say that the
culture of science has become so rotten
that this sort of thing is maybe
standard operating procedure just
protecting their ass and protecting the
ass of those who give them jobs and and
all the work that's been done that sort
of establishes that they should be doing
these tests in the first place I'm sure
they tell themselves some story in which
they're the heroes and they are
protecting us from something but I I
look at my own medicine cabinet and even
though I am aware of what likely
happened I am in no position to protect
myself or my family the only way to be
protected from the downstream
consequences of this error is to just
not take pharmaceuticals Jesus Christ
yeah
it's it's a it's a really huge problem
and the response of the system generally
to shut down the lone individual trying
to point out a serious problem is it's
just breathtaking and when you've when
you've seen it when you lived it you you
never go back
you know you've looked into the eye of
something that is willing to ignore
I mean it's willing to ignore it not
only human life but it is willing to
ignore the requirements of good science
how could you leave an error like that
undescribed and how is this being
discussed on a [ __ ] comedians podcast
why is this not front page the New York
Times why is this not leading on the
news when you're talking about the
safety of pharmaceutical drugs huh how
is this not something that's an enormous
story well this this raises another
question something I actually wanted to
set the record straight about by and
large I thought Eric did a fantastic job
of describing this in fact we're here at
the the tail end of this podcast and
we're both tired and I feel like I've
done a much worse job than he did
describing the science but I wanted to
correct one thing and I think it will
help answer the question you just asked
me you asked Eric why I had not pursued
this and you said maybe was he afraid
and Eric indicated that that was some
part of it it's no part of it and I
think Eric has actually forgotten what
happened so I was dogged about this for
a decade I tried everything I could
think of I talked to every journalist
who would listen as I said I went to the
Committee on drug safety the Blue Ribbon
Commission I did everything I could
think of I wrote and when Carol Greider
who refused to acknowledge my
contribution got her Nobel Prize I wrote
what I think was a generous op-ed in The
New York Times saying that her Nobel
Prize was deserved but that we had this
serious problem related to Mouse
telomeres and that maybe now this Nobel
Prize would give us the courage
look at it they wouldn't publish it so I
tried everything I could think of and at
one point a good friend of ours guy
named Mike Brown who used to he was the
former CFO of Microsoft really good guy
I made a ton of money because he was at
Microsoft in the ground floor and he
used to hold something he called science
camp in science camp involved gathering
a bunch of really high quality people to
talk privately where nobody was aware
that we were even gathered right it
really gave us the room to be frank and
I was there and I gave a talk on
telomeres I gave a talk about the
science and I talked about the politics
that had that I'd run into and you know
they were blown away it was you know
it's it's jaw-dropping stuff and
afterwards Eric and Mike took me aside
and they said you know we understand why
this is having the effect on you that
it's having but you're wrapped around
the axle that was their phrase you're
wrapped around the axle about the story
it's preventing you from doing what you
need to do and I didn't like hearing
that
and I you know initially I thought no
that's not right and then I think I
think they were right and so I let it go
and I started I only talked about it
with my students from that point forward
I tried to teach the science as clearly
as I could and try to keep the politics
as far away from it as I could and you
know it's very hard to do but I let it
go now at that point I was a obscure
college professor at an obscure college
I had 400 Twitter followers I wasn't in
a position to push the case if somebody
didn't want to hear it eric is right
that we are in a different era I have
three hundred thousand Twitter followers
a hundred and thirty thousand YouTube
subscribers
I got powerful friends it is possible
that that is enough to get this raised
at the level that it would need to be
raised in order to get it addressed but
I'm not convinced of that my experience
trying to get the topic addressed
anywhere for more than a decade was that
it was it was like having a big hammer
and there's a bell and you keep running
at the Bell and slamming it with the
hammer and there's no sound it does not
ring there's nothing that you can do to
make it ring now maybe maybe at this
higher profile there is now enough
firepower to get that bell to ring but
Eric's podcast which is probably among
the best places if you want to know the
scientific story to go to you can listen
to his the portal number 19 and you can
hear him you know he catches me off
guard he forces me to tell this story
which I didn't I should have seen it
coming but I didn't so anyway you get
the the raw version it is possible that
we are now going to get the bell to ring
but but episode 19 of the portal did not
cause it to ring it caused a flurry of
activity outside of mainstream
scientific circles but it did not cause
anybody to sit up and take notice
inside and that is the thing I think we
still don't know we don't know what
force were up against the pharmaceutical
industry has mice that will tell us that
drugs that they are advancing into the
market are safe when they are not and
maybe that's the force that prevents the
Bell from ringing I really have no idea
but I guess the question is is the era
different because we're at a higher
profile or isn't it it seems like we
would need more than just the scientific
community we'd need some someone else in
media to press the scientific community
and say what's going on here the press
the pharmaceutical industry and say
address this is this an issue or is it's
not an issue is he correct if he is
correct what do we do about this and
what does this mean what do we do about
this and how many other this is are they
I happened on this completely by
accident I happened on this because I
was a generalist who was interested in
interesting things and I was interested
in evolution and this just happened to
show up and so yeah I pursued it there
were features of my character that
caused me to
pursue it when others would have let it
go but it still indicates that there may
be many such things lurking that we have
no awareness of and that the fact that
systems are so good at shutting down a
story like this means that it would be
very unlikely that you would have heard
that there was a flaw like this so I
don't know I don't know the answer to
your question I do think you know your
point about the foundation being the
important place to dealing with you know
the the rotten structure above is not
where this has to go it's got to go to
the bottom level what we are finding out
is that in system after system something
has gone wrong I think there are a small
number of themes that explain why these
systems go wrong I think we have taken
the magic of market forces which really
are magic for certain things and we have
infused them where they do harm rather
than good in other words in my opinion
markets are excellent at figuring out
how to do things and they are terrible
at deciding what to do and we have put
them in charge of both jobs so we are so
in love with the magic of what they can
accomplish that we don't realize that
they you know science for example is too
delicate to allow market forces to
government if you let market forces
govern it it becomes like any other
market and it turns scientists into
salesmen and things like that we have to
get good at figuring out where we can
afford to use the market where we have
to insulate something from the market
and at the point we do that we'll be in
a much stronger position to protect
ourselves but until we do we're just
gonna keep doing self harm and on that
note you know Joe I was really hoping
that this would be funnier I had a I had
a tight ten minutes that I was gonna
dribble out over three hours and I think
didn't do it he brought up some awesome
stuff really very very important points
across the board very brave points to
and I always appreciate you man really
do Thanks
and I really appreciate you two if it is
not clear your podcast which you have
built is one of the few things of its
magnitude that is not corrupt which is
why I think you have so many good people
willing to come here at the drop of a
hat and talk to you so have you no idea
how it happened let's just keep doing it
all right
thanks man thanks brother bye everybody
[Music]